and barely right so luminary has really
created an ecosystem now around the
world because we're no longer just in
new york to really give tools to women
to advocate for themselves to create
their own sense of how do i push through
the pipeline the companies shinali that
you know that we work with jpmorgan ubs
goldman warburg pincus
and so many more they're really thinking
about not only how do they attract and
hire how do they retain and part of this
is giving their women the tools to
negotiate better to self-advocate to
think about opportunities and upward
mobility and we've that is how we're
going to change the numbers in addition
to companies really taking
responsibility for promoting earlier and
promoting more often so kate you're
really honing in on uh the tools the
tools that people need and i i like that
phrase that you use push and pull
because it really seems like it's not
one or the other and these both need to
happen at the same time in order for us
to actually see some change is that what
you're saying
absolutely you know i i and i spent a
very long time as i mentioned in
corporate and investment banking and one
of the things that i learned really
early on from great male peers mentor
sponsors was you got to be out there
talking about yourself authentically but
talking about your accomplishments
talking about the value that you bring
to the organization to the team to the
firm and that was you know 20 something
years ago why aren't more women feeling
comfortable do this well in our study it
says i feel anxiety i feel like there's
retribution or repercussions and i fear
being labeled aggressive right you just
heard from the the summit yesterday that
why is ambition a bad thing for women i
feel like we have to embrace these
skills and actually really learn to
understand what it means to self-promote
and self-advocate it's not bragging if
it's based on facts you know another
thing here that i've been wondering you
have seen people hire more diverse
workforces in the entry level try to
make their promotion classes more
diverse kate one thing that worries me
about this is that people are getting
titles but the pay is not matching
absolutely is that what's happening and
you know what is problematic about this
phenomenon i mean what is keeping people
from pay equity at the end of the day
so i think there's a couple of things
right we know when these particularly
the you know the big companies they they
bring their classes in more diverse
absolutely it's great fifty percent of
the pipeline is women but we also know
as they progress through the pipeline
they do it more slowly they're often
paid and proponent on performance versus
potential that's an issue there's also
an issue with salary transparency great
let's know what everyone makes but
there's always still a range and it's
usually left to the manager's discretion
we know
that at the senior levels there are
still more men in those positions and
not that someone should be paid more
just because of their gender or their
representation but they should be paid
on potential and that's where we're
seeing an issue as you go through the
pipeline that disparity becomes larger
and larger that's why you see these
numbers sixty percent say it's an issue
with compensation forty percent believe
that they're making less than their
white male peers
and 82 percent feel like i'm definitely
not compensated commensurate to my
experience and my background in my role
compared to my male peers this is not a
hit on men right we love men we need
them as part of our journey that we we
need to acknowledge the challenges that
exist
from a company level but also as
individuals right we cannot expect
accomplishments to speak for themselves
maybe we've been told that there's a big
societal cultural issue in this but
we've got to self-advocate and luminary
has been doing this literally since we
launched three years ago
day in and day out and that's why when
we got the results of this study it
wasn't a huge surprise to me because we
see it with all of the companies that
are part of our community that we work
with this is still probably the number
one issue
kate thank you so much for your time we
hope to continue the discussion that's
kate luzio founder and ceo of luminary
all right we're back in two minutes this
is quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we are
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
schafer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
[Music]
do
all right we are continuing with our
focus of the day shanali you're of
course obviously speaking with a lot of
company leaders when we talk about the
company aspect what is it that they're
doing because we were just hearing kate
talk about this push and pull that needs
to happen in order to make the play the
workplace more equitable yeah it's
interesting i'll use a study by ariel
investments for example where a lot of
employees feel that their employers are
just checking the box here and what
you're seeing is even with the addition
of more board members they're not
necessarily being put in the positions
that affect change when it comes to pay
more diverse suppliers and also frankly
a lot of women and people of color are
leaving very prominent spots in the
workforce so here now to talk about this
issue how to bring change from the top
down is natasha lam she's partner uh
managing partner and co-founder of
arjuna capital a sustainable and impact
investment firm natasha thank you for
being here you've really waged so many
interesting campaigns pushing for
changes at the biggest companies in the
world can you bring us inside some of
the most interesting campaigns that
you've had when it comes to pay equity
yes thank you so much for having me
happy to be here this morning and
continue this conversation
i think it's a really important one um
we actually spearheaded an investor
campaign on pay equity going back to
2015
um and started pressing the companies in
our portfolio to disclose and close pay
gaps across race and gender and when we
started that work uh no companies were
releasing data on these gaps and what we
understood
is that um
you know if you're not paying women and
people of color fairly um you're not
going to pull from 100 of the talent
pool attract and retain top talent
um and really have a competitive
business you know we started working
with the tech firms the wall street
banks the big retailers um and and it's
a huge issue there and over the years i
mean we've now
as a firm um have successfully pressed
25 companies um to disclose their pay
gaps across race and gender
uh and you know and we're still doing
that even a couple weeks ago we had a
vote go
um
to disney's annual meeting asking for uh
pay equity reporting pay gap reporting
got a nearly 60 percent vote of
investors
which was the largest vote in the
company's history
and a very rare uh majority vote for
investors so uh continuing to press
companies on this issue natasha you
mentioned disney which i think i think
is pretty interesting because they've
been in the news a lot for some of their
workplace conditions and their pay
how do they stack up in terms of the
things that you are analyzing and what
are some of the other companies
that you're taking a look at
sure um yeah i mean disney gets an f and
uh you've probably heard uh among some
other criticisms but they've had a lot
of litigation on pay equity in
california um
it's clearly been an issue for the
company uh and but you know the fact of
the matter is disney's not alone you
know i i'm sure there's
there are very
few companies uh that have no pay gaps
um particularly when you're looking
on a median basis and the definition of
the pay gap um is you know what are
women paid versus men on the median it's
83 cents in this country um what are
people of color paid versus their white
um you know white peers um
black workers in this country are paid
64 cents on the dollar uh and and what
we're really pressing for is
transparency
and publishing those gaps and closing
and narrowing them over time so you know
here you've got disney getting an f uh
we actually saw meta or facebook fall
two full letter grades we put out an
annual score card every year um looking
at these this disclosures we just put
out our fifth uh scorecard on equal pay
day meta fell two full letter grades
because they stopped publishing
quantitative data during the pandemic
and you know gosh that's you know the
pandemic was such a one-two punch for
women and people of color who suffered
80 of the job losses in 2020
that's the wrong time to stop publishing
uh and really managing this data um and
only of of the companies that we that we
scored that was 57 companies only seven
received a grades and that was um pfizer
which is you know kind of fitting uh
given the pandemic they they hit the top
mark and then mastercard bank of new
york mellon starbucks adobe american
express and citigroup all of whom we've
worked for and worked with and pushed
to publish these disclosures natasha
it's interesting you know some of those
companies that i spoke to one thing that
they mentioned to me is that some of the
greatest pressures coming from
washington rather than from investors
where are you seeing the greatest
pressure come in terms of changing the
company's behavior
so you know as i said when we started
this work we weren't seeing any data be
published um being published and we uh
a couple years in the united kingdom
started mandating public disclosure of
median pay gaps um which did apply
pressure
even on u.s companies because they had
to publish pay camps for their uk
operations and you know we've since said
okay you're publishing it for the uk
you're showing big gaps you need to do
that for your global operations um there
have been
uh you know some mandates to public to
share data with the government
that data is not public um so it's
certainly not helpful for investors
because we can't see how companies are
stacking up um and what we know from
some of the studies is that if this data
is public if there's transparency if
there's an honest accounting then
companies actually manage
it more you know you you you manage what
you measure basically we all know that
old adage um but you know even going
back a few years ago there was a white
house uh pay pledge um and companies all
you know sort of ran to sign up and you
know the problem with that is it just
gave them cover oh we signed this pay
pledge but investors their employees
still didn't know um what pay gaps
looked like at the company and if they
were narrowing over time it's all about
disclosing it you cannot just pay play
lip service natasha lam managing partner
and co-founder of arjuna capital thank
you so much natasha for your time uh
chanel definitely seeing some
improvements there uh but a lot more to
go yeah a lot more to go and honestly as
much as improvements we are seeing
companies fall behind so holding people
accountable here right that's what we do
here at quick take but that'll do it for
a quick take this hour uh there's more
quick take coming up in just a minute
i'm jennifer zabasanja and i'm sonali
basic you can check out the latest
stories at bloomberg.com or at quicktake
on social media thanks for watching
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this young man is dakota assembler
and he has it all
a flamingo pattern car
an office that couldn't quit 1971.
a bunch of surplus military gear
and then
this incredible machine
an all-electric semi-truck
that is both a salute
and a giant middle finger to elon musk
[Music]
dakota is the ceo of a two-year-old
company called thor trucks based in
north hollywood
thor is one of a handful of companies
trying to bring electric drive trains to
really big vehicles
really we set out to solve the issue
that fleets are having right now with
diesel vehicles a lot of that surrounds
our compliance maintenance the cost of
fuel cost of energy and so we were
trying to set out to solve a lot of
those problems that fleets have
in november elon musk unveiled this
sucker at an event in la
musk said the tesla semi-rig will cost
180 thousand dollars
go 500 miles on a single charge and
recharge in about 30 minutes when it
arrives at the end of 2019.
i came to visit thor to see what a
real-life electric semi can do today
thor got started in a warehouse when
dakota bought a diesel truck and hired a
team to convert it
they replaced the engine with an
electric motor
they built some battery packs
and they slapped a giant screen in the
cab
tell me about the logo it looks almost
like tesla meets transformers kind of
thing part of what we're trying to do is
really exude kind of the power that evs
can provide when you think about evs
particularly when you're talking about
commercial vehicles people like they're
weak they're they're not strong thor's
hammer yeah and it's tough and it's a
brand that people will really come to be
known as kind of the tough ev brand
this prototype truck is called et1
and tom here agreed to take me out for a
spin with his mustache
when i first looked at the truck i
thought
i thought well
don't quite know that's gonna work
electric trucks are gonna cost more than
diesel rigs have shorter driving ranges
and require a charging infrastructure to
be built but tom thinks they have a
chance
the way this thing pulls is
really unbelievable for an electric
vehicle so you were surprised the first
time
yeah
i was shocked more like
if nothing else the truck is good at
getting attention
no this is a thor truck this is yeah
it's electric
no i'm serious i'll show it to you
no you see the electric motor
thor expects this truck to cost 150 000
for 300 miles of range when it goes on
sale in 2019
and they're quiet run clean and have
amazing pickup you know the power in
this thing is unbelievable the way it
takes off and the way it handles it's
it speaks for itself yeah
thor has 18 employees including a
handful with deep electric vehicle
expertise
the startup bills itself as an electric
auto lab that will make all kinds of
custom vehicles including things like
delivery and garbage trucks
thor will have a hell of a time going up
against giants like tesla and daimler
since they have you know actual
factories and experience
but la has long been home to high-risk
custom auto projects
tesla's early operations didn't look
much different than these
we set up prototyping tools really early
on because we realized that was a vital
part of being able to build quickly and
produce something that we could actually
start demonstrating and showing to
customers
this warehouse has been in dakota's
family for three generations
first as a depot for making and selling
military-grade electronics and then as a
storage spot for the family's malibu
wines vineyard
dakota started working here when he was
seven and eventually ran the family wine
business and started at safari tours so
the hollywood elite can get drunk and
hang out with giraffes
there's tons of inspiration in this
place tucked in the corner is this
beauty this is a 1918 walker electric
panel van
this vehicle was fully electric battery
electric vehicle from the early turn of
the century
what did they use it for
so deliveries this was actually one of
like a milk delivery vehicle or an ice
delivery vehicle so this would be a
range of about 15 miles 12 to 15 miles
okay
everybody here is incredibly committed
this isn't a project that we're trying
to do or gain a bunch of notoriety we
want to actually make these things exist
in fleets we're actually driven to to
make this viable business and not just a
science project
and if things don't pan out dakota can
always hop in his rv
hit the road and go soul searching for
his next venture
i'm sure this beast runs great on
electricity too
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick
[Music]
take access the financial world on
demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts the alive and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
conventional wisdom these days says that
robots will soon put millions of factory
workers out of jobs
this may sound like the fever dream of
dr evil but in fact there are very
pleasant people making this happen
may i introduce suzanne gildert a
budding ai overlord and founder of
toronto startup kindred ai
[Music]
tell me about these guys
so these are research prototypes
so they're some of the first robots we
built at kindred
we tend to work with small robots it's a
bit like if you imagine a child growing
up and it breaks a lot of things now
imagine if the child was six feet tall
when it had the brain of a six month old
it would be terrible
terribly dangerous how many of these
robots have ever slapped you
i have been hit in the face by robots a
couple of times
suzanne seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital art
and she loves cats to the point where
she's built a robotic fleet of them for
the office
this one i believe is called pink foot
[Music]
it's a quadruped robot loosely based on
a cat anatomy although it's not a very
highly faithful representation yet
and then when you were growing up you
would build things as well yeah that's
correct yeah
so i was really enthralled by
electronics at an early age
i guess most little girls would be
looking at trays of beads and things and
i was looking at trays of like resistors
and capacitors and little components but
having the same kind of reaction to them
but don't be fooled by the hobby
electronics and the cute cat bots
[Music]
suzanne is a keen businesswoman
and kindred has recently embarked on its
first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running uh picking up
objects
these would run all day all day all
night
powered by state-of-the-art ai these
arms can do something that's very easy
for a human but very hard for a bot
pick up objects of different shapes
and put them down
most factories still use people to do
that sort of thing
lots and lots of people
today everyone's shopping on e-commerce
thousands and thousands of different
types of objects shapes textures weights
how do you pick that up
right now it's human so you have
millions of humans in warehouses just
like picking up things and putting it
into another location so we're teaching
our robots how to do that
[Music]
what's the hard part it's figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it yeah exactly it's
fine how to pick it up right so things
will show up in any shape right and you
got to figure out how to pick it up
without dropping it
put it in the location so it takes a lot
of training
part of that training involves of all
things humans
robot pilots who manually control the
arms while the ai watches and learns the
finer points of grabbing
all right ma'am teach me how to use it
have a seat
[Music]
so you see a 3d mouse here this lets you
navigate the arm through
three-dimensional space so imagine
you're holding the arm in that left hand
and you're just moving it around
move it slowly and gently
there you go
trying to get the oreos
i gotta go up oh shoot i went too far up
i want these oreos
[Laughter]
you kill
[Laughter]
come them to the arm
there
success
it's like being at the arcade basically
it's like you actually get to win
something
just down the hall kindred keeps a room
full of pilots doing the same thing as
me
only these guys are actually competent
they're remotely overseeing some arms in
a gap factory a thousand miles away in
tennessee
[Music]
how long have you been a robot pilot uh
just over a month actually i've only
been here five weeks what was the
training process like almost like
playing a video game
it's like a shirt gone that's a backpack
that's a backpack okay
somebody's undies oh there it goes yeah
one shirt at a time
[Music]
as the arms observe their human guides
they gradually learn how to do better at
picking up t-shirts and shoe boxes
eventually they'll be fully autonomous
and size services will no longer be
required
one day this is just going to light up
and it's going to be picking the objects
pretty much pretty much that's that's
the ultimate end goal for at least for
these to have it just constantly wearing
and going
and the people will be free
the people will be free to do other more
important things
seemed kind of happy about the prospect
of unemployment
but i was concerned for his future
[Music]
isn't there something grim about the
human training there
and yeah it's not good to take people's
jobs away but this kind of technology
coming into the workforce should make us
start thinking about how we're going to
pay people in the future because ai is
not just going to automate you know
manual labor jobs it's going to automate
things like doctors and lawyers and
accountants very soon so i think there's
going to be issues there's going to be a
lot of disruption when these things come
online
suzanne is a realist
but she's also an optimist
in her vision of the future robots won't
be mindless competitors to humanity
they'll be full-fledged citizens like
the rest of us
one of the crazy ideas i see you talking
about was you've got a robot and
it's working in a factory and then it's
got to go maybe it gets paid a wage and
it goes to buy lithium ion batteries to
keep it going why would that have to
happen i mean if you're having a
physical body they will have a lot of
physical needs just like we have
you might have to go to their repair
shop to get like a motor look tag or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that i think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to explore new things they've never
seen before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to perhaps rest so that
their mind has time to consolidate all
this new information i keep trying to
picture it in my head though so this is
the robot workers we go home and sit on
the couch and watch tv after work and
he's i don't see why not i probably
watch cat videos
it's hard to tell sometimes if suzanne
is laughing with us or at
us either way i plan to clear a nice
spot on the couch for my robot friends
oil up some delicious popcorn and smile
politely
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
this is jeff hinton
because of a back condition he hasn't
been able to sit down for more than 12
years
i hate standing i'd much rather sit down
but if i sit down i have a disc that
comes out
sorry
well at least now standing desks are
fashionable and yeah but i was ahead
i was standing where i was standing when
they weren't
since he can't sit in the car or on a
bus
hinton walks
everywhere
[Music]
the walk says a lot about hinton and his
results
for nearly 40 years hinton has been
trying to get computers to learn like
people do a quest almost everyone
thought was crazy or at least hopeless
right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field
google thinks this is the future of the
company amazon thinks the future company
apple thinks it's a future company my
own department thinks this stuff's
probably nonsense and we shouldn't be
doing any more
so i took everybody into it except my
own department
[Music]
you obviously grew up in the the uk and
you had this very prestigious family
full of famous mathematicians and
economists and i was you know i was
curious what it was like for you
yeah there was a lot of pressure
um i think by the time i was about seven
i realized i was gonna have to get a phd
um
did you rebel against that or you you
went along i dropped out every so often
yeah i became a carpenter for a while
jeff hinton pretty early on became
obsessed with this idea of figuring out
how the mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain worked then
he got into psychology
and then finally he settled on more of a
computer science approach to modeling
the brain and got into artificial
intelligence
my feeling is if you want to understand
a really complicated device like a brain
you should build one
i mean you could look at cars and you
could think you could understand cars
when you try and build a car you
suddenly discover that there's this
stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work yeah
as jeff was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some ai
researchers across the pond
specifically this guy
frank rosenblatt
rosenblatt
in the late 1950s developed what he
called a perceptron and it was
a neural network a computing system that
would mimic the brain
the basic idea is a collection of small
units called neurons these are little
computing units but they're actually
modeled on the way that the human brain
does its computation
they take incoming data like we do from
our senses and they actually learn so
the neural net can learn to make
decisions over time
rosenblatt's hope was that you could
feed a neural network a bunch of data
like pictures of men and women and it
would eventually learn how to tell them
apart
just like humans do
there was just one problem
it didn't work very well
rosenblatt his neural network was a
single layer of neurons
and it was limited in what it could do
extremely limited
and a colleague of his wrote a book in
the late 60s that showed these
limitations
and it kind of put the whole area of
research into a deep freeze for a good
10 years no one wanted to work in this
area they were sure it would never work
well
almost no one
it was just obvious to me that it was
the right way to go
the brain's a big neural network and so
it has to be that stuff like this can
work because it works in our brains
there's just never any doubt about that
and what do you think it was inside of
you that
kept you wanting to pursue this when
everyone else was giving up just that
you thought it was the right direction
to go no that everyone else was wrong
okay
[Laughter]
hinton decides he's got an idea of how
these neural nets might work and he's
gonna pursue it no matter what
for a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the u.s
he kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the defense department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go
i didn't want to take defense department
money i sort of didn't like the idea
that this stuff was going to be used for
purposes that i didn't think were good
[Music]
he suddenly hears that canada might be
interested in funding artificial
intelligence
and that was very attractive that i
could go off to this civilized town
and just get on with it
so i came to the university of toronto
and then in the mid 80s we discovered
how to make more complicated neural nets
so they could solve those problems that
the simple ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layered neural network a deep
neural network
and this started to work in a lot of
ways
using a neural network a guy named dean
pomerleau built a self-driving car in
the late 80s and it drove on public
roads
jan lacoon in the 90s built a system
that could recognize handwritten digits
and this ended up being used
commercially
but again they hit a ceiling
they didn't work quite well enough
because we didn't have enough data we
didn't have enough compute power
and people in ai and computer science
have decided neural networks was wishful
thinking basically
so it was a big disappointment
through the 90s into the 2000s jeff was
one of only a handful of people on the
planet who are still pursuing this
technology
he would show up at academic conferences
and be banished to the back rooms he was
treated as really like a pariah
was there like a time when you thought
this just wasn't gonna work and and you
you did have some self-doubt i mean i
there were many times when i thought i'm
not gonna make this work
but jeff was consumed by this and
couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn until about 2006
when the world catches up to hinton's
ideas
[Music]
computers were down a lot faster
and now it's behaving like i thought it
would behave in the mid 80s it's solving
everything
the arrival of super fast chips and the
massive amounts of data produced on the
internet gave hinton's algorithms a
magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image
then they could recognize speech
and translate from one language to
another
by 2012 words like neural nets and
machine learning were popping up on the
front page of the new york times
you have to go all these years and then
all of a sudden you know in this span of
a few months
it just takes off did it finally feel
like aha you know the world has finally
come to my vision it was sort of a
relief that people finally came to their
senses
for hinton this was clearly a redemptive
moment after decades of toil
and for canada it meant something even
bigger
hinton and his students put the country
on the map as an ai superpower
something no one
and no computer
could ever have predicted
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
market
good morning and welcome to quick take
charge i'm jennifer zabasaja live in new
york on this wednesday morning later in
the show we're going to take a look at
new data on workplace equity for our
focus of the day but first we are going
to start with kovid's fifth wave yes i
said fifth wave more than a third of
last week's u.s kova 19 cases were
caused by the omicron ba2 subvarian
according to the cdc that's a notable
increase from a week earlier when the
strain was estimated to account for just
under one in four cases the shift
follows a trend seen in several
countries overseas upticks are visible
again in the uk france and italy
infection rates in both austria and
germany are also surpassing previous
waves of the of the virus and china is
also grappling with new highs in terms
of case counts president biden's advisor
dr anthony fauci said earlier this week
he doesn't think we'll see a surge here
in the u.s but that quote this virus has
fooled us before and we really must be
prepared for the possibility that we
might get another variant and we don't
want to be caught flat-footed on that so
here now to discuss is dr amit shadalja
he is a senior scholar with the johns
hopkins center for health security at
the bloomberg school of public health
and also sam fazeli bloomberg senior
pharmaceutical analyst with bloomberg
intelligence sam i want to start with
you what exactly do we know about this
ba2 omicron variant and how exactly it
differs from the ba1 omicron variant
that a lot of people were infected with
earlier this year
hi um
so i think there are some people who
even suggest that perhaps we should not
be calling ba ii a sub variant of
omicron because it has
pretty meaningful and substantial
changes in the amino acid sequence in
the sequence that makes up the so-called
spike protein and perhaps in some other
areas so but whatever the terminology is
going to have to be what we do know
about it is that from the data so far
the immunity that you get from a omicron
previous omicron infection or maybe one
of the other sub-variants d a spot one
spot one
seems to be sufficient to protect you
against a
an early reinfection with the ba2 we
also know that the vaccines seem to be
equally effective based on our own
analysis of data from countries such as
denmark which have had a major wave of
ba2 and also seeing some recent
publications from qatar so from all
those perspectives it suggests that
based on the data so far in the real
world the um vaccines are similarly
effective and then an infection is about
the same as if you have got a ba1 one
but dr adalja given what sam just said
this is also coming at a time where many
people's uh you know protection against
the virus is maybe waning because we're
a few months out from the booster shot
so is that a concern to you
it all depends upon what our goals are
with this pandemic because
to me i think it's inevitable that cases
are eventually going to go up that we're
going to see more contagious variants
like ba two appear but if those cases
are increasingly mild meaning they don't
require hospitalization or they can be
intervened upon with antivirals and
monoclonal antibodies and you don't see
hospitals in crisis i think that's the
situation we always were aiming for with
a virus like sars kov2 one that couldn't
be eradicated or eliminated it's going
to be very important though for people
who are not vaccinated to get vaccinated
and it's going to be important for
immunocompromised people to be quickly
linked to care if they get sick and to
continue to be vigilant when they're in
high risk situations but the virus isn't
going anywhere and i think this is sort
of the new normalcy that we will
continue to see this become a seasonal
respiratory virus that has ebbs and
flows and hot spots that that keep
cropping up but when does it become an
area of concern dr adalja
to me it becomes an area of concern when
you see hospitals worrying about
capacity when they're worried about not
having enough room to take care of
patients that to me is what this
pandemic has always been about that's
when
that's when we're really in crisis when
we can't have the healthcare system
functioning the way it should and and
that's happened during that happened
during delta that happened in the early
days of the pandemic it less so happened
during omicron because many of those
cases were mild and not not as as sick
as we saw in the past but that's what
we're trying to do is tame the virus
shift its spectrum to the mild side and
i think
it's unlikely that ba2 is going to be
able to crush hospitals in the u.s
because we've got enough immunity from
infection and vaccination plus tools
like antivirals and monoclonal
antibodies that will likely see this
shift to the outpatient side
and that's where we want to be
sam i'd love for you to respond to that
especially because in your note uh with
one of our colleagues as well you talk
about how covid we do have to start
living with it um but we have to learn
to live with it but we can't ignore it
so does that mean we should still be
having some of the precautions that we
had like masks like you know not
gathering in big groups being extra
cautious on planes what's your take
yeah i think i i have to say that dr
adelgid
explained it perfectly well there
currently our biggest issue is worrying
about whether there's going to be a run
on hospitals again and severe disease
but in terms of
our behavior i think what i think course
anybody else thinks
is kind of irrelevant people have moved
on i think to roll back
a requirement for masks again um in
public spaces on public transport etc
really enforcing it is going to be very
tough unless there's a tangible feeling
of danger out there but that people will
regard us and we've told them enough
times now that this is potentially a bit
milder than the other variants so far
which is probably a lot to do with
vaccination levels etc but i think one
thing that we are not talking about
enough is this issue of long covet
granted there is a lot of um hope and
some data that suggests that people who
are fully vaccinated i want to read
stress again people are fully vaccinated
possibly needing three doses have a
lower risk of developing longer-term
symptoms
but
there are still some and there are all
sorts of things that that are coming out
of the woodwork with regards to diabetes
brain issues a lot of which are probably
general reaction to a viral infection i
don't know about the details for a fact
but that's something that i think we
can't forget and if we have high levels
of infection running around even if
we're not seeing hospitalizations we
need to keep a very close eye on that
sam is that reason for a fourth shot
then
i can't i'm not going to go there i'm
i'm
i'm really sitting on the fence about
fourth shots there is little doubt in my
mind that at some point perhaps ahead of
the winter
for the
more compromised people you want to call
them immunocompromised because of
disease or age perhaps the fourth shot
will be useful but i don't know from the
data that i'm seeing again out of qatar
with the efficacy of a third chart
whether really even against domicron
hospitalizations whether really you need
a
a fourth shot and let's not forget the
effect of a fourth shot will contract
again
it won't last very long against an
infection so we'll be constantly chasing
our tail on that yeah dr adelsia i know
you've particularly sort of shared that
same sentiment as sam not really being
uh for a fourth shot but as we've
mentioned in the uk um some older adult
adults are are getting a fourth shot at
this time
well i think you have to spray where the
fourth shot is actually effective if
you're a high risk individual third
shots and four shots make sense but for
the general healthy population i don't
think the third or four shots make much
of a difference because they give you a
transient benefit against what's a mild
illness we know that the vaccine in
healthy people the standard two dose
regimens of the mrna vaccines are
holding up against what counts serious
illness hospitalization and death these
first-generation vaccines that their
booster effect wears off and i don't
think boosting to prevent mild illness
in healthy people makes sense with these
first generation vaccines so
immunocompromised people high-risk
people there they need a different
vaccine strategy but it shouldn't be a
one-size-fits-all because remember it's
first and second doses that keep people
out of the hospital when i see patients
in the hospital with covid it's
predominantly people with that are
lacking first and second doses not
lacking third and fourth doses yeah and
when we talk about uh preventing another
crisis i thought it was interesting to
um hearing dr fauci talking specifically
about funding which is also sam you
mentioned something that's not talked
about a lot funding is another aspect of
this that we may if we don't have the
right funding we're not going to be able
to protect ourselves going
forward amish can you explain why that
is and what exactly this funding that
congress would approve uh would go
towards is it the fourth shot is there
something else here
the funding is for a lot of the medical
countermeasures that i mentioned
antivirals monoclonal antibodies booster
vaccine doses diagnostic tests and some
money to cover uninsured individuals and
i think the problem we have now is that
all of these things are mostly available
as emergency use authorization products
and the government is the only buyer the
only distributor there's no commercial
market if you want to buy a monoclonal
antibody or tax limit there's no
commercial market yet and until the
government transitions this to a
commercial market they need funds to
purchase them or we won't have these
tools that we're so much relying on to
keep our hospitals afloat so that's the
issue is that we're in this situation
where we're still in emergency phase
when it comes to the medical
countermeasures and there's no other way
to get them unless the government buys
them and distributes them to the states
that's the problem we're in right now
sam can you just close this out i mean
how soon does this need to be approved
in order to be effective
i think i think currently obviously the
case counts in the u.s are looking uh on
a plateau it is possible that we're
going to see a bump perhaps due to ba2
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Music]
less than four months i've proven that
you can have the venn diagram of
exceptional talent that is more than 70
percent diverse the firm might be
wide-owned but there's a lot of of
subcontract work that they do that could
be a black owned business and we really
put that into our contracts to try and
get those second tiers built up if you
want people
to be consumers of your product and
visit your locations then you have to be
thoughtful uh about policies that you
may be selling about when you think
about the things that hold us back you
know to hold like marginalized
marginalized communities back
it's like a gravity right and those
those three pillars are essentially
disproportionate access to education
healthcare medicine and also
representation wouldn't you want to hide
the smartest people in the room they're
going to include women and people of
color and it's easy to assume that
they're comfortable with the world that
they're in that they're not as ambitious
as the men but that's not a safe
assumption
and those were just a few of the
attendees from yesterday's bloomberg
equality summit discussing concrete ways
to make change in the workplace and
beyond and it ties to our by the numbers
where we give you the data that tells
the story this morning's number is 73
a new report out this month from
luminary and indeed shows that roughly
three in four women believe that female
workers who self-advocate for themselves
are perceived more negatively than men
who do the same by their employers only
half of the respondents think women of
color are supported when they
self-advocate in the workplace meanwhile
75
believe companies support the
self-advocacy efforts of white men and
65 percent of white women and that is
why workplace equity is our quick take
focus of the day chanelle basic is
joining me now shanael i think
self-advocacy isn't something that's
always discussed uh when we talk about
work equity but when you look at some of
these numbers that luminary highlighted
you realize sort of the role that it
plays in achieving equity for everybody
yeah and it's truly disappointing that
you know there is this pay gap but if
women or people of color advocate for
themselves they're perceived negatively
and so it's a problem for employees it's
a problem for customers who are not
getting diverse
companies to be buying from and by the
way you know something that was
interesting in the panel was that that
first woman you heard from and that was
your panel yeah my panel one thing that
struck me is after a woman spent 30
years on wall street at jpmorgan salomon
brothers citigroup you know she felt
that she spent so much time trying to
change the system from within and then
just left and formed her own company
you're seeing a lot of that happen now
on wall street and in corporate america
here now to talk about this issue is
kate luzio she's the founder and ceo of
luminary a new york city-based
collaboration hub for
professionals kate thank you for being
here i know you work with a lot of these
companies i know you worked on wall
street yourself and and left and formed
luminary
what is uh the the latest issue that
you're seeing here for employees who are
trying to seek equity in their
workplaces
well it's great to be here and i love
listening to anne she was one of my
mentors when she was at jp morgan and
love seeing what she's doing
and she's a great friend uh you know the
issue here is we rely so much on
companies to pull us up through the
pipeline and we absolutely should and
they have a responsibility to invest in
the pipeline much earlier and often you
know that's one of the reasons why i
left my long very long career in banking
um to create luminary to have impact and
actually provide the skills that women
need in order to push themselves through
the pipeline this is all about push and
pull
companies pulling up women pushing up
and i think self-advocacy is something
that is missing throughout the pipeline
when we looked at this study and this is
the third study we've done in the last
two years
it's glaringly obvious right we know
that pay is an issue 60 of those
surveyed said compensation is an issue
it's going to be a deal breaker but yet
50
of women said i'm going to make a change
then the next year not necessarily
resign but i'm gonna make a change so if
you're gonna make a change and you feel
like you're not being paid enough and
you feel like others in particular the
male gender are self-advocating more why
are only 40
feeling like they advocate and barely
right so luminary has really created an
ecosystem now around the world because
we're no longer just in new york to
really give tools to women to advocate
for themselves to create their own sense
of how do i push through the pipeline
the companies chanale that you know that
we work with jp morgan ubs goldman
warburg pincus
and so many more they're really thinking
about not only how do they attract and
hire how do they retain and part of this
is giving their women the tools to
negotiate better to self-advocate to
think about opportunities and upward
mobility and we've that is how we're
going to change the numbers in addition
to companies really taking
responsibility for promoting earlier and
promoting more often so kate you're
really honing in on uh the tools the
tools that people need and i i like that
phrase that you use push and pool
because it really seems like it's not
one or the other and these both need to
happen at the same time in order for us
to actually see some change is that what
you're saying
absolutely you know i i and i spent a
very long time as i mentioned in
corporate and investment banking and one
of the things that i learned really
early on from great male peers mentor
sponsors was you got to be out there
talking about yourself authentically but
talking about your accomplishments
talking about the value that you bring
to the organization to the team to the
firm and that was you know 20 something
years ago why aren't more women feeling
comfortable do this well in our study it
says i feel anxiety i feel like there's
retribution or repercussions and i fear
being labeled aggressive right you just
heard from the the summit yesterday that
why is ambition a bad thing for women i
feel like we have to embrace these
skills and actually really learn to
understand what it means to self-promote
and self-advocate it's not bragging if
it's based on facts
you know another thing here that i've
been wondering you have seen people hire
more diverse workforces in the entry
level try to make their promotion
classes more diverse kate one thing that
worries me about this is that people are
getting titles but the pay is not
matching absolutely is that what's
happening and you know what is
problematic about this phenomenon i mean
what is keeping people from pay equity
at the end of the day
so i think there's a couple of things
right we know when these particularly
the you know the big companies they they
bring their classes in more diverse
absolutely it's great 50 of the pipeline
is women but we also know as they
progress through the pipeline they do it
more slowly they're often paid and
proponented on performance versus
potential that's an issue there's also
an issue with salary transparency great
let's know what everyone makes but
there's always still a range and
it's usually left to the manager's
discretion we know that at the senior
levels there are still more men in those
positions and not that someone should be
paid more just because of their gender
or their representation but they should
be paid on potential and that's where
we're seeing an issue as you go through
the pipeline that disparity becomes
larger and larger that's why you see
these numbers sixty percent say it's an
issue with compensation forty percent
believe that they're making less than
their white male peers
and 82 percent feel like i'm definitely
not compensated commensurate to my
experience and my background in my role
compared to my male peers this is not a
hit on men right we love men we need
them as part of our journey that we we
need to acknowledge the challenges that
exist
from a company level but also as
individuals right we cannot expect
accomplishments to speak for themselves
maybe we've been told that there's a big
societal cultural issue in this but
we've got to self-advocate and luminary
has been doing this literally since we
launched three years ago
day in and day out and that's why when
we got the results of this study it
wasn't a huge surprise to me because we
see it with all of the companies that
are part of our community that we work
with this is still probably the number
one issue
kate thank you so much for your time we
hope to continue the discussion that's
kate luzio founder and ceo of luminary
all right we're back in two minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market
but that perform better you are building
a portfolio it's much like you know
cooking a meal and etfs i just think
make investing just so convenient and
easy trillian's etf masterchef only on
quick take
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick
[Music]
[Music]
do
all right we are continuing with our
focus of the day chanali uh you're of
course obviously speaking with a lot of
company leaders when we talk about the
company aspect what is it that they're
doing because we were just hearing kate
talk about this push and pull that needs
to happen in order to make the pla the
workplace more equitable yeah it's
interesting i'll use a study by aerial
investments for example where a lot of
employees feel that their employers are
just checking the box here and what
you're seeing is even with the addition
of more board members they're not
necessarily being put in the positions
that affect change when it comes to pay
more diverse suppliers and also frankly
a lot of women and people of color
leaving very prominent spots in the
workforce so here now to talk about this
issue how to bring change from the top
down is natasha lam she's partner
managing partner and co-founder of
arjuna capital a sustainable and impact
investment firm natasha thank you for
being here you've really waged so many
interesting campaigns pushing for
changes at the biggest companies in the
world can you bring us inside some of
the most interesting campaigns that
you've had when it comes to pay equity
yes thank you so much for having me
happy to be here this morning and
continue this conversation
i think it's a really important one um
we actually spearheaded an investor
campaign on pay equity going back to
2015
and started pressing the companies in
our portfolio to disclose and close pay
gaps across race and gender and when we
started that work uh no companies were
releasing data on these gaps and what we
understood
is that um
you know if you're not paying women and
people of color fairly
you're not going to pull from 100 of the
talent pool attract and retain top
talent
um and really have a competitive
business you know we started working
with the tech firms the wall street
banks the big retailers um and and it's
a huge issue there and over the years i
mean we've now
as a firm um have successfully pressed
25 companies um to disclose their pay
gaps across race and gender
uh and you know and we're still doing
that even a couple weeks ago we had a
vote go
um
to disney's annual meeting asking for uh
pay equity reporting pay gap reporting
got a nearly 60 percent vote of
investors uh which was the largest vote
in the company's history um and a very
rare uh majority vote for investors so
uh continuing to press companies on this
issue natasha you mentioned disney which
i think i think is pretty interesting
because they've been uh in the news a
lot for some of their uh workplace
conditions and their pay how do they
stack up in terms of the things that you
are analyzing and what are some of the
other companies
that you're taking a look at
sure um yeah i mean disney gets an f and
you've probably heard
among some other criticisms but they've
had a lot of litigation on pay equity in
california um
it's clearly been an issue for the
company uh and but you know the fact of
the matter is disney's not alone you
know i i'm sure there's
there are very
few companies uh that have no pay gaps
particularly when you're looking um on a
median basis and the definition of the
pay gap um is you know what are women
paid versus men on the median it's 83
cents in this country um what are people
of color paid versus their white um you
know white peers um
black workers in this country are paid
64 cents on the dollar uh and and what
we're really pressing for is
transparency
and publishing those gaps and closing
and narrowing them over time so you know
here you've got disney getting an f uh
we actually saw meta or facebook fall
two full letter grades we put out an
annual score card every year um looking
at these this disclosures we just put
out our fifth uh score card on equal pay
day meta fell two full letter grades
because they stopped publishing
quantitative data during the pandemic
and you know gosh that's you know the
pandemic was such a one-two punch for
women and people of color who suffered
80 of the job losses in 2020.
that's the wrong time to stop publishing
uh and really managing this data um and
only of of the companies that we that we
scored uh that was 57 companies only
seven
received a grades and that was um pfizer
uh which is you know kind of fitting uh
given the pandemic they they hit the top
mark and then mastercard bank of new
york mellon starbucks adobe american
express and citigroup all of whom we've
worked for and worked with and pushed
to publish these disclosures natasha
it's interesting you know some of those
companies that i spoke to one thing that
they mentioned to me is that some of the
greatest pressures coming from
washington rather than from investors
where are you seeing the greatest
pressure come in terms of changing the
company's behavior
so you know as i said when we started
this work we weren't seeing any data be
published um being published and
we
a couple of years in the united kingdom
started mandating public disclosure of
median pay gaps
um which did apply pressure um even on
u.s companies because they had to
publish pay camps for their uk
operations and you know we've since said
okay you're publishing it for the uk
you're showing big gaps you need to do
that for your global operations um there
have been
uh you know some mandates to public to
share data with the government
that data is not public um so it's
certainly not helpful for investors
because we can't see how companies are
stacking up um and what we know from
some of the studies is that if this data
is public if there's transparency if
there's an honest accounting then
companies actually manage
it more you know you you you manage what
you measure basically we all know that
old adage um but you know even going
back a few years ago there was a white
house uh pay pledge um and companies all
you know sort of ran to sign up and you
know the problem with that is it just
gave them cover oh we signed this pay
pledge but investors their employees
still didn't know um what pay gaps
looked like at the company and if they
were narrowing over time it's all about
uh disclosing it you cannot just play uh
lip service natasha lam managing partner
and co-founder of arjuna capital thank
you so much natasha for your time uh
chanel definitely seeing some
improvements there but a lot more to go
yeah a lot more to go and honestly as
much as improvements we are seeing
companies fall behind so holding people
accountable here right that's what we do
here at quick take but that'll do it for
a quick take this hour uh there's more
quick take coming up in just a minute
i'm jennifer zabasanja and i'm sonali
basic you can check out the latest
stories at bloomberg.com or at quicktake
on social media thanks for watching
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafak tune in
to watch those who shape our world
explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artists
and dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to
the novelist and political scientist
elif shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stephen lawrence was murdered because he
was black few crimes in recent times
have had such a profound or long lasting
impact
injustice watershed landmark are all
used to describe the lawrence case the
thing that makes lawrence particularly
important
and why i think the stephen lawrence
case is the case that is
apparently changed the nation
is because it hinges on something else
so the the the murder itself was just
jaw dropping and
nobody could grasp that
but what
followed was just beyond anybody's
imagination
[Music]
i remember the steven lance case very
well it was the day before my daughter's
birthday so it was the 22nd of april
1993 and i remember i remember it
extremely well
it's hard to it's hard to describe it in
any other way as just
almost sport
i suspect i suspect for an american
audience you would be able to really
relate to this and perhaps this is why
it was so shocking because although we
it wasn't in any sense that kind of you
know us down south mississippi lynching
it wasn't far off
this is the bus stop where stephen
lawrence was brutally stabbed to death
in a savage racial attack today the bus
stops being changed there are even new
benches but it does nothing to diminish
the fact that this point represents the
very worst in british race relations
you had two boys stephen and his friend
who were at a bus stop in southeast
london one evening and
they were
part of an absolutely unprovoked attack
where one of the boys managed to escape
stephen stanley didn't and five uh young
white men um
murdered him
and as we discovered as the story
unfolds and the the press and the media
were able to get behind the story of the
stephen's murderers um these people had
practiced these kinds of assaults and
killings in their bedrooms and also it
was just the most extraordinary thing um
and it was the premeditated nature of it
i think people found so very very
difficult
in the days following stephen's murder
the police received several tip-offs and
all sources pointed to the same five
suspects
brothers neil and jamie are court gary
dobson luke knight and david norris
their gang were named 26 times as
stephen lawrence's killers in the hours
following his murder lawrence handed in
her own list of suspects only to see the
officer first fold it up and then screw
it into a ball in front of her
the mets failure to respond to initial
reports would prove to be the first in a
string of injustices against the
lawrence family that spanned more than
two decades
a couple of weeks later and still no
arrests
the lawrence family had a press
conference airing their frustrations
that not enough was being done to catch
the killers
two days later they met with nelson
mandela
nelson mandela paused on a visit to
britain to publicly shake the lawrence's
hands
in private they talked he listened when
no one in authority would
we are
very used to this type of thing where
life
is regarded as cheap in south africa
and but nevertheless uh it's a sense of
deep concern that it should happen in a
country like britain
so we had these two huge problems we had
this issue with a young man in a london
street who could be murdered but in a
dif in addition to the murder uh we were
confronted with this extraordinary
notion of the ineptitude of the
police inquiry that was motivated
by race
it's a racist society
that it doesn't matter
as for a black person that is it doesn't
matter what standard of life you try to
achieve for yourself it makes no
difference in cases like this you're
treated as if you're criminal right from
the start
in 1994 a year after the murder covert
video filmed by the police over several
days in one of the suspect's apartments
showed the gang using knives and making
violent racist remarks
with the investigation going nowhere and
a growing sense that the system had
failed them stephen's parents took
matters into their own hands
in 1996 dorian and neville lawrence took
out a private prosecution against three
suspects
this was the first private prosecution
for murder in the uk for more than a
century
but the lawrence's would once again
leave without justice
the judge directed the jury to return
not guilty verdicts
identification evidence was ruled
inadmissible and there was not enough
other evidence to justify the
prosecution
the three suspects were acquitted and
the entering of not guilty verdicts
meant they could not be tried again
i think one of the things that makes the
racism arguments such an interesting one
is that there is a there there is the
difference i think between individual
racism and institutional racism so and i
think that um most people would be asked
at the idea of being accused of being
racist
but
because we live so comfortably in a
racist system it's difficult to
reconcile those two points yourself
evidently the system is racist
in 1997 the lawrence family registered a
formal complaint with the police
complaints authority about the mets
handling of the investigation
soon after the daily mail and national
newspaper ran a front page accusing the
men of killing lawrence and challenging
them to sue for libel
i think that i think the daily mail's
involved was really very surprising if
you think about the daily mail the daily
mail's the sort of fox news of the uk
broadcasting environment and this was
very much a cnn story if you'd like if i
can put it that way for you and the fact
that it was actually
fox news in the form of daily mail but
went to bat on this and actually
published the extraordinary headline
murderers with a picture of the these
young men
was a massive stance
with growing interest around the case
from both the media and the public
pressure was on the newly elected labour
administration to take action
by the summer of 1997 the new home
secretary jack straw met with the
lawrences and soon after the home office
announced a judicial inquiry into the
police's handling of the case
this inquiry will have full powers to
compel the attendance of witnesses to
give evidence under oath and if they
fail to do so to punish them as if it
were a contempt of court
the inquiry led by retired high court
judge sir william mcpherson sat for 59
days to hear evidence from 88 witnesses
and produced more than one hundred
thousand pages of documents
at the heart of this inquiry is the
allegation from the lawrence's and their
lawyers that racism permeated the police
investigation into stephen's death and
permeates the society in which it
happened
so it's become a touchstone for the
black community and the outcome could
point to the direction of the future of
race relations in britain
the gang came to give evidence at the
public hearing having been told they
will face prosecution otherwise
a huge crowd gathered outside the
hearing hoping to get a chance to see
them take the stance
at the inquest the five suspects refused
to answer questions the inquest jury
ruled stephen had been unlawfully killed
in a completely unprovoked racist attack
tensions between the police the public
and the suspects reached boiling point
outside the court
the inquiry was adjourned for three
hours after police fired cs gas on
protesters
the men spat and hit out of the crowd as
police escorted them back to their
vehicles
in 1999 two years after the inquiry
began macpherson made 70 recommendations
and delivered a damning final verdict
he
he concluded in his uh
really landmark report um that the
metropolitan police service was indeed
institutionally racist
these 70 kind of overarching
recommendations were presented to the
metropolitan police force and the
metropolitan police force um to be
honest has been um
having a very um
a very complicated time engaging with it
the chairman of the inquiries the
william mcpherson repeatedly challenged
the paul about widespread instinctive
racism within the force but sepal
continually rebutted that suggestion
um i find it difficult after five years
for the commissioner to
still be saying that he felt that there
was no racism
or corruption involved in stephen's case
so if that wasn't racism and it wasn't
corruption i still hadn't given the
answer as to why stephen's pillars are
still walking free
the inquiry prompted some serious
changes within the police force and led
to the race relations amendment act in
2000 that strive to eliminate
discrimination and promote racial
equality
but the problem of racism
is
it's so
deeply woven into the fabric of our
society
that it is by no means a simple thing to
resolve
the inquiry may have shone light on
institutional racism but it didn't bring
the result the lawrence family so
desperately wanted the conviction of
their son's murderers
in the 11 years since there have been
three murder investigations two police
reviews and a public inquiry yet his
killers still remain free now the crown
prosecution service says it's unlikely
the case will ever be solved
but then in 2005 double jeopardy the
rule preventing suspects being tried
twice for the same crime was scrapped
something macpherson had recommended in
his report six years earlier
but with no new evidence this offered
the lawrence family little hope
at every turn uh the lawrence case makes
history
they they literally challenged every
step of the way and whatever obstacle
was in the place statue law and so on
they just overturned it
a tiny spot of blood found on the collar
of dobson's jacket has a one in a
billion chance of not belonging to
stephen
other fibers from the dead teenager's
clothing were allegedly found on a
multi-coloured cardigan
using the latest forensic technology new
evidence was found during a cold case
review of lawrence's murder that tied
two of the previously acquitted suspects
to the case
in 2011 the trial of gary dobson and
david norris for lawrence's murder
begins in light of the new evidence
it took a long time for justice to ride
out in the lawrence case doreen watched
the many suspects in her son's murder
walk free from courts and inquiries 19
years later only two of them have been
convicted a failure she says of
politicians
as well as the police
[Music]
it was 19 years later
19 years let me say that again before
dobson and norris were in prison
so there are two things about that
they're extraordinary one is it took 19
years for them to be
brought to
brought to court again and charged with
found guilty and two is that
19 years later
baroness lawrence was still as resilient
and as as
as committed to this as she was 19 years
previously
we pay tribute to mr and mrs lawrence's
courage and dignity
they have contributed to major changes
within policing the law
and indeed within society as a whole
dorian lawrence continued to campaign
for justice for her son as well as for
other victims of racist crime
in 2013 doreen was awarded the title of
baroness for her relentless work within
the community
she has been um
you know really really really uh
embedded in this psyche of this nation
because of the work that she's done and
the sacrifice she's paid it it's hard to
explain it in terms of what it looks
like but it was it was yeah in in a way
it was our own
it was our probably the most important
criminal justice struggle
in terms of the black story in this
country in the last however many years
policing has long been a focal point for
concerns over racial injustice in the uk
and despite changes sparked by the
lawrence case and the landmark
macpherson inquiry black people and
ethnic minorities in britain are still
disproportionately represented when it
comes to police checks imprisonment and
deaths in custody
we need to remember that the uk is not
innocent we are a physical
representation of our support for george
floyd we are a physical representation
of our support for stephen lawrence
i think there is a very challenging
conversation to be had about race and a
challenging conversation about racism
i think there is enough evidence to
suggest
that um
racism
is a
is in is in the dna of this nation
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
scottish city glasgow once held a grim
title the murder capital of europe
but homicides in the city have fallen by
60
in just over a decade all thanks to a
radical approach
treating violence as a disease
here's how scotland is curing violent
crime
growing levels of alcohol abuse
unemployment and inequality between the
1980s and early 2000s had contributed to
a social crisis in scotland
by 2005 the crime rate had reached its
highest levels in a decade and the
united nations released a report which
named scotland as the most violent place
in the developed world
but it was in scotland's largest city
glasgow where the problem was most
severe
nightly i can anticipate around a dozen
calls for gang fighting on the street or
group disorder outside somebody's home
this high concentration of gang violence
had pushed glasgow's murder rate almost
three times higher than the rest of the
country but in 2005 in response to the
growing crisis glasgow's regional police
force set up the violence reduction unit
or vru
it became the only police force in the
world to take a public health approach
to violence that meant treating violence
as a preventable disease rather than
just as a criminal matter
the vru's new strategy was inspired by
the work of gary slutkin an american
physician who'd spent a decade fighting
cholera and aids epidemics across africa
during the 80s and 90s
when he came back to chicago slutkin was
confronted with another epidemic gun
violence but i can get a gun anytime i
won't
after mapping crime data he noticed that
violence followed the same patterns as
contagious diseases
one act led directly to another and
these were often found clustered
together he also found that violence
could be transmitted between people
if a person was exposed to violence it
increased the likelihood that they would
commit violence
in 2000 slutkin created a pilot project
on the west side of chicago which
controlled outbreaks of violence in a
similar way to health epidemics and
focuses on three key areas
first to find the cause of an outbreak
and interrupt its transmission to other
people this work is carried out by
violence interrupters people with an
established relationship with the
community who can help identify symptoms
and eliminate the root causes of
violence
second is to identify people who might
be at risk of developing violent
behaviour and try to prevent it from
happening this is done by offering
alternatives to gang membership through
employment housing and health support
finally an important step is to change
attitudes towards violence making
communities understand that it's
something preventable not inevitable
this approach has been adapted by the
violence reduction unit in scotland but
as well as helping people break free
from violence the viu has also advocated
for stronger penalties for those who
continue on a path of crime
through lobbying the penalty for
carrying a knife in scotland has tripled
in 10 years
by 2006 scotland had extended the work
of the vru nationwide and during the
following decade violent crime fell by
49 percent including murders which were
reduced by 47
these dramatic reductions have helped to
ease the burden on the scottish
healthcare system with hospital
emergency assault admissions down by 56
since 2007
and the benefits of a reduced crime rate
are economic too each homicide case in
the uk is estimated to cost the taxpayer
2.3 million dollars which is more than
the cost of running the vru for an
entire year
while scotland is aiming to achieve the
lowest levels of crime in the world by
2025 at the other end of the country
london has seen a recent surge in knife
crime in the year to may 2018 there were
97 fatal stabbings
and so the uk capital has announced it
will be one of many cities around the
world looking to follow scotland's
example in the hope of breaking the
cycle of violence
[Music]
anti-gun activists in the us have been
pushing for gun law reform australia
having made substantial changes to its
gun laws is often held as an example the
country has a very low rate of gun
related homicide when compared to the us
where people are at least 20 times more
likely to be murdered by firearms
stricter gun controls can't stop every
mass shooting but they have made
australia a significantly safer place
here's how
australia used to have a serious problem
with gun violence researchers define
mass shootings as five or more deaths
not including the perpetrator from 1979
to 1996 there were 13 mass shootings
resulting in over 100 deaths and more
than 50 injuries
however due to the gun lobby and
politicians sympathetic to their firearm
owning voters little was done to stop
gun deaths being a politician and living
in that bloody house
is the most important thing to them
in april 1996 that all changed
on the island of tasmania the worst
massacre in australian history is
finally over at least 34 people were
killed and four others critically
wounded armed with two rifles an ar-15
and a 308 fn martin bryant made his way
through port arthur historic site
killing 35 people and injuring a further
23. both guns were semi-automatic
rapid-fire weapons and both were legal
in the state of tasmania at the time the
port arthur massacre was the worst
single-person mass shooting in global
history it utterly shocked australians
and reignited public outrage
just 12 days later the then prime
minister john howard pushed through a
sweeping set of gun regulations despite
a lack of support from his rural
constituency
[Music]
within a month the government passed the
national firearms agreement transforming
gun legislation in the country
before the port arthur massacre gun laws
varied from state to state what the
agreement did was standardize the laws
nationally certain semi-automatics and
self-loading rifles and shotguns were
banned new licensing requirements were
adopted and a national firearms registry
was established the law says australians
need a genuine reason for having a
firearm such as sports shooting or for
agricultural use it doesn't include
self-defense people must go through
background checks and wait 28 days
before they can buy a gun
[Music]
the government also spent
375 million us dollars to buy back 640
000 civilian-owned guns and then
destroyed them
after the gun law reform the total
number of homicides involving a firearm
decreased by half the total number of
gun related deaths fell rapidly as well
dropping more than half in 2016 compared
with 1996. australia didn't see a single
mass shooting from 1996 to 2018 more
than 22 years
however anti-gun activists warned that
following years of lobbying by pro-gun
groups australia's strict gun laws have
been eroded and gun numbers are almost
back to the same level as at the time of
the port arthur massacre
in may 2018 a family of seven including
four children was shot dead in an
apparent murder-suicide in the state of
western australia this brought back
painful memories and uncertainty about
the issue many thought had been resolved
australia is not totally immune to mass
shootings but its response to the port
arthur massacre demonstrated how strong
political leadership and strict gun
control policies can help curb violence
and save lives
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to quick take
charge i'm jennifer zabasaja live in new
york on this wednesday morning later in
the show we're going to take a look at
new data on workplace equity for our
focus of the day but first we are going
to start with kovid's fifth wave yes i
said fifth wave more than a third of
last week's u.s kova 19 cases were
caused by the omicron ba2 subvarian
according to the cdc that's a notable
increase from a week earlier when the
strain was estimated to account for just
under one in four cases the shift
follows a trend seen in several
countries overseas upticks are visible
again in the uk france and italy
infection rates in both austria and
germany are also surpassing previous
waves of the of the virus and china is
also grappling with new highs in terms
of case counts president biden's advisor
dr anthony fauci said earlier this week
he doesn't think we'll see a surge here
in the u.s but that quote this virus has
fooled us before and we really must be
prepared for the possibility that we
might get another variant and we don't
want to be caught flat-footed on that so
here now to discuss is dr amish adalja
he is a senior scholar with the johns
hopkins center for health security at
the bloomberg school of public health
and also sam fazeli bloomberg senior
pharmaceutical analyst with bloomberg
intelligence sam i want to start with
you what exactly do we know about this
ba2 omicron variant and how exactly it
differs from the ba1 omicron variant
that a lot of people were infected with
earlier this year
hi um
so i think there are some people who
even suggest that perhaps we should not
be calling ba2 a sub-variant of omicron
because it has pretty meaningful and
substantial changes in the amino acid
sequence in the sequence that makes up
the so-called spike protein and perhaps
in some other areas so but whatever the
terminology is going to have to be what
we do know about it is that from the
data so far
the immunity that you get from a omicron
previous omicron infection or maybe one
of the other sub-variants ea spot one
spot one
seems to be sufficient to protect you
against a
an early reinfection with the ba2 we
also know that the vaccines seem to be
equally effective based on our own
analysis of data from countries such as
denmark which have had a major wave of
ba2 and also seeing some recent
publications from qatar so from all
those perspectives it suggests that
based on the data so far in the real
world the um vaccines are similarly
effective and then an infection is about
the same as if you have got a ba1 but dr
adalja given what sam just said this is
also coming at a time where many
people's uh you know protection against
the virus is maybe waning because we're
a few months out from the booster shot
so is that a concern to you
it all depends upon what our goals are
with this pandemic because
to me i think it's inevitable that cases
are eventually going to go up that we're
going to see more contagious variants
like ba two appear but if those cases
are increasingly mild meaning they don't
require hospitalization or they can be
intervened upon with antivirals and
monoclonal antibodies and you don't see
hospitals in crisis i think that's the
situation we always were aiming for with
a virus like czar's cov2 one that
couldn't be eradicated or eliminated
it's going to be very important though
for people who are not vaccinated to get
vaccinated and it's going to be
important for immunocompromised people
to be quickly linked to care if they get
sick and to continue to be vigilant when
they're in high risk situations but the
virus isn't going anywhere and i think
this is sort of the new normalcy that we
will continue to see this become a
seasonal respiratory virus that has ebbs
and flows and hot spots that keep
cropping up but when does it become an
area of concern dr adolja
to me it becomes an area of concern when
you see hospitals worrying about
capacity when they're worried about not
having enough room to take care of
patients that to me is what this
pandemic has always been about that's
when there that's when we're really in
crisis when we can't have the healthcare
system functioning the way it should and
and that's happened during that happen
during delta that happened in the early
days of the pandemic it less so happened
during omicron because many of those
cases were mild and not not as as sick
as we saw in the past but that's what
we're trying to do is tame the virus
shift its spectrum to the mild side and
i think
it's unlikely that ba2 is going to be
able to crush hospitals in the u.s
because we've got enough immunity from
infection and vaccination plus tools
like antivirals and monoclonal
antibodies that will likely see this
shift to the outpatient side
and that's where we want to be
sam i'd love for you to respond to that
especially because in your note with one
of our colleagues as well you talk about
how covid we do have to start living
with it
but we have to learn to live with it but
we can't ignore it so does that mean we
should still be having some of the
precautions that we had like masks like
you know not gathering in big groups
being extra cautious on planes what's
your take
yeah i think i i have to say that dr
adelgid
explained it perfectly well there
currently our biggest issue is worrying
about whether there's going to be a run
on hospitals again and severe disease
but in terms of
our behavior i think what i think of
anybody else's thinks
is kind of irrelevant people have moved
on i think to roll back
a requirement for masks again
in public spaces on public transport etc
really enforcing it is going to be very
tough unless there's a tangible feeling
of danger out there that people will
regard us and we've told them enough
times now that this is potentially a bit
milder than the other variants so far
which is probably a lot to do with
vaccination levels etc but i think one
thing that we are not talking about
enough is this issue of lung covid
granted there is a lot of um hope and
some data that suggests that people who
are fully vaccinated i want to read
stress again people are fully vaccinated
possibly needing three doses have a
lower risk of developing longer-term
symptoms
but there are still some and there are
all sorts of things that that are coming
out of the woodwork with regards to
diabetes brain issues a lot of which are
probably general reaction to a viral
infection i don't know about the details
for a fact but that's something that i
think we can't forget and if we have
high levels of infection running around
even if we're not seeing
hospitalizations we need to keep a very
close eye on that sam is that reason for
a fourth shot then
i can't i'm not going to go there i'm
i'm i'm really sitting on the fence
about fourth shots there is little doubt
in my mind that at some point perhaps
ahead of the winter
for the
more compromised people you want to call
them immunocompromised because of
disease or age perhaps the fourth shot
would be useful but i don't know from
the data that i'm seeing again out of
qatar with the efficacy of a third chart
whether really even against omicron
hospitalizations whether really you need
a um a fourth shot and let's not forget
the effect of a fourth shot will
contract again
it won't last very long against an
infection so we'll be constantly chasing
our tail on that yeah dr adelsia i know
you've particularly sort of shared that
same sentiment as sam not really being
at four or four shot but as we mentioned
in the uk um some older adult adults are
are getting a fourth shot at this time
well i think you have to spray where the
fourth shot is actually effective if
you're a high risk individual third
shots and four shots make sense but for
the general healthy population i don't
think that third or four shots make much
of a difference because they give you a
transient benefit against what's a mild
illness we know that the vaccine in
healthy people the standard two dose
regimens of the mrna vaccines are
holding up against what counts serious
illness hospitalization and death these
first generation vaccines that their
booster effect wears off and i don't
think boosting to prevent mild illness
in healthy people makes sense with these
first generation vaccines so immuno
compromised people high risk people
there they need a different vaccine
strategy but it shouldn't be a
one-size-fits-all because remember it's
first and second doses that keep people
out of the hospital when i see patients
in the hospital with covid it's
predominantly people with that are
lacking first and second doses not
lacking third and fourth doses yeah and
when we talk about uh preventing another
crisis i thought it was interesting to
um hearing dr fauci talking specifically
about funding which is also sam you
mentioned something that's not talked
about a lot funding is another aspect of
this that we me if we don't have the
right funding we're not going to be able
to protect ourselves going forward amish
can you explain why that is and what
exactly this funding that congress would
approve uh would go towards is it the
fourth shot is there something else here
the funding is for a lot of the medical
countermeasures that i mentioned
antivirals monoclonal antibodies booster
vaccine doses diagnostic tests and some
money to cover uninsured individuals and
i think the problem we have now is that
all of these things are mostly available
as emergency use authorization products
and the government is the only buyer the
only distributor there's no commercial
market if you want to buy a monoclonal
antibody or tax limit there's no
commercial market yet and until the
government transitions this to a
commercial market they need funds to
purchase them or we won't have these
tools that we're so much relying on to
keep our hospitals afloat so that's the
issue is that we're in this situation
where we're still in an emergency phase
when it comes to the medical
countermeasures and there's no other way
to get them unless the government buys
them and distributes them to the states
that's the problem we're in right now
sam can you just close this out i mean
how soon does this need to be approved
in order to be effective
i think i think currently obviously the
case counts in the u.s are looking
on a plateau it is possible that we're
going to see a bump perhaps due to ba2
there are some people who argue maybe it
won't be as bad as what we're seeing in
the uk or not but it doesn't matter if
it's not b8 it will be another variant
the the funding has to be in place soon
as soon as possible so that all these
measures are are available and put in
place and
and you're able to get going as soon as
something happens we have we have to be
humble in the face of this virus and
that is taught us you got to be ready
not react ready not react uh i couldn't
think of any two people better to talk
about this really appreciate both of you
guys amish adalja senior scholar with
the johns hopkins center for health
security at the bloomberg school of
public health and also sam fazeli
senior pharmaceutical analyst for
bloomberg intelligence thank you so much
and we should note the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health is
supported by michael r bloomberg founder
of bloomberg lp and bloomberg
philanthropies
all right now let's get you a few other
stories on our radar that we don't want
you to miss this morning first off
president biden is heading to europe
tomorrow where he'll try to rally ali
allies around tougher sanctions to
punish russia for invading ukraine the
president will join back-to-back summits
thursday in brussels with nato the group
of seven and the european union the
stakes have been raised by the fear that
russia could resort to deploying weapons
of mass destruction
also judge katanji brown jackson is
getting closer to becoming the first
black woman on the u.s supreme court in
a marathon day of testimony yesterday
before a senate panel she held her own
against a barrage of republican attacks
centering around crime and race
republicans have all but conceded that
jackson will more than likely be
confirmed and finally one of the
favorite meme stocks gamestop kept its
rally going in pre-market trading shares
of the video game retailer surged today
after rising 31 percent on tuesday
gamestop chairman ryan cohen disclosed
that he has raised his stake in the
company to almost 12
and you can always learn more about
these stories and stay up to date on the
day's news at bloomberg.com now we're
back in two minutes with our focus of
the day this is quick take charge
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter this is my new
show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
[Music]
do
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world bloomberg
[Music]
less than four months i've proven that
you can have the venn diagram of
exceptional talent that is more than 70
diverse the firm might be wide owned but
there's a lot of of subcontract work
that they do that could be a black owned
business and we really put that into our
contracts to try and get those second
tiers built up if you want people to be
consumers of your product and visit your
locations then you have to be thoughtful
uh about policies that you may be
selling about when you think about the
things that hold us back you know to
hold like marginalized marginalized
communities back
it's like a gravity right and those
those three pillars are essentially
disproportionate access to education
healthcare medicine and also
representation wouldn't you want to hide
the smartest people in the room they're
going to include women and people of
color and it's easy to assume that
they're comfortable with the world that
they're in that they're not as ambitious
as the men but that's not a safe
assumption those were just a few of the
attendees from yesterday's bloomberg
equality summit discussing concrete ways
to make change in the workplace and
beyond and it ties to our by the numbers
where we give you the data that tells
the story this morning's number is 73
percent a new report out this month from
luminary and indeed shows that roughly
three in four women believe that female
workers who self-advocate for themselves
are perceived more negatively than men
who do the same by their employers only
half of the respondents think women of
color are supported when they
self-advocate in the workplace meanwhile
75 percent believe companies support the
self-advocacy efforts of white men and
65 percent of white women and that is
why workplace equity is our quick take
focus of the day chanelle basic is
joining me now chanali i think
self-advocacy isn't something that's
always discussed when we talk about work
equity but when you look at some of
these numbers that luminary highlighted
you realize sort of the role that it
plays in in achieving equity for
everybody yeah and it's truly
disappointing that you know there is
this pay gap but if women or people of
color advocate for themselves they're
perceived negatively and so it's a
problem for employees it's a problem for
customers who are not getting diverse
companies to be buying from and by the
way you know something that was
interesting in the panel was that that
first woman you heard from and that was
your panel yeah as my panel one thing
that struck me is after a woman spent 30
years on wall street at jpmorgan salomon
brothers citigroup
you know she felt that she spent so much
time trying to change the system from
within and then just left and formed her
own company you're seeing a lot of that
happen now on wall street and in
corporate america here now to talk about
this issue is kate luzio she's the
founder and ceo of luminary a new york
city-based collaboration hub for
professionals kate thank you for being
here i know you work with a lot of these
companies i know you worked on wall
street yourself and and left and formed
luminary what is the the latest issue
that you're seeing here for employees
who are trying to seek equity in their
workplaces
well it's great to be here and i love
listening to ann she was one of my
mentors when she was at jpmorgan and
love seeing what she's doing
and she's a great friend
you know the issue here is we rely so
much on companies to pull us up through
the pipeline and we absolutely should
and they have a responsibility to invest
in the pipeline much earlier and often
you know that's one of the reasons why i
left my long very long career in banking
to create luminary to have impact and
actually provide the skills that women
need in order to push themselves through
the pipeline this is all about push and
pull
companies pulling up women pushing up
and i think self-advocacy is something
that is missing throughout the pipeline
when we looked at this study and this is
the third study we've done in the last
two years
it's glaringly obvious right we know
that pay is an issue 60 of those
surveyed said compensation is an issue
it's going to be a deal breaker but yet
50 of women said i'm gonna make a change
then the next year not necessarily
resign but i'm gonna make a change so if
you're gonna make a change and you feel
like you're not being paid enough and
you feel like others in particular the
male gender are self-advocating more why
are only 40 percent feeling like they
advocate and barely right so luminary
has really created an ecosystem now
around the world because we're no longer
just in new york to really give tools to
women to advocate for themselves
to create their own sense of how do i
push through the pipeline the companies
chanale that you know that we work with
jpmorgan ubs goldman warburg pincus
and so many more they're really thinking
about not only how do they attract and
hire how do they retain and part of this
is giving their women the tools to
negotiate better to self-advocate to
think about opportunities and upward
mobility and we've that is how we're
going to change the numbers in addition
to companies really taking
responsibility for promoting earlier and
promoting more often so kate you're
really honing in on the tools the tools
that people need and i i like that
phrase that you use push and pull
because it really seems like it's not
one or the other and these both need to
happen at the same time in order for us
to actually see some change is that what
you're saying
absolutely you know i i and i spent a
very long time as i mentioned in
corporate and investment banking and one
of the things that i learned really
early on from great male peers mentor
sponsors was you got to be out there
talking about yourself authentically but
talking about your accomplishments
talking about the value that you bring
to the organization to the team to the
firm and that was you know 20 something
years ago why aren't more women feeling
comfortable do this well in our study it
says i feel anxiety i feel like there's
retribution or repercussions and i fear
being labeled aggressive right you just
heard from the the summit yesterday that
why is ambition a bad thing for women i
feel like we have to embrace these
skills and actually really learn to
understand what it means to self-promote
and self-advocate it's not bragging if
it's based on facts
you know another thing here that i've
been wondering you have seen people hire
more diverse workforces in the entry
level try to make their promotion
classes more diverse kate one thing that
worries me about this is that people are
getting titles but the pay is not
matching absolutely is that what's
happening and you know what is
problematic about this phenomenon i mean
what is keeping people from pay equity
at the end of the day
so i think there's a couple of things
right we know when these particularly
the you know the big companies they they
bring their classes in more diverse
absolutely it's great fifty percent of
the pipeline is women but we also know
as they progress through the pipeline
they do it more slowly they're often
paid and promoted on performance versus
potential that's an issue there's also
an issue with salary transparency great
let's know what everyone makes but
there's always still a range and it's
usually left to the manager's discretion
we know
that at the senior levels there are
still more men in those positions and
not that someone should be paid more
just because of their gender or their
representation but they should be paid
on potential and that's where we're
seeing an issue as you go through the
pipeline that disparity becomes larger
and larger that's why you see these
numbers sixty percent say it's an issue
with compensation 40
believe that they're making less than
their white male peers um and 82
feel like i'm definitely not compensated
commensurate to my experience and my
background in my role compared to my
male peers this is not a hit on men
right we love men we need them as part
of our journey that we we need to
acknowledge the challenges that exist
from a company level but also as
individuals right we cannot expect
accomplishments to speak for themselves
maybe we've been told that there's a big
societal cultural issue in this but
we've got to self-advocate and luminary
has been doing this literally since we
launched three years ago
day in and day out and that's why
when we got the results of this study it
wasn't a huge surprise to me because we
see it with all of the companies that
are part of our community that we work
with this is still probably the number
one issue
kate thank you so much for your time we
hope to continue the discussion that's
kate luzio founder and ceo of luminary
all right we're back in two minutes this
is quick take charge
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding
you have athletes and you have
influencers as clients i'd assume
they're into crypto are you getting them
exposure we're absolutely overlaying it
on the portfolio what's your favorite
ticker it's the best ticker ever it
really kind of captures the themes what
you're trying to always deliver is a
very simple solution and if you can
deliver that simple solution powerfully
i think that resonates quite well in the
market tell us about this portfolio
where's that spice going to come from
we're looking for portfolios that have
less risk than the market but that
perform better you are building a
portfolio it's much like you know
cooking a meal and etfs i just think
make investing just so convenient and
easy trillian's etf masterchef only on
quick take
[Music]
all right we are continuing with our
focus of the day chanali uh you're of
course obviously speaking with a lot of
company leaders when we talk about the
company aspect what is it that they're
doing because we were just hearing kate
talk about this push and pull that needs
to happen in order to make the play the
workplace more equitable yeah it's
interesting i'll use a study by aerial
investments for example where a lot of
employees feel that their employers are
just checking the box here and what
you're seeing is even with the addition
of more board members they're not
necessarily being put in the positions
that affect change when it comes to pay
more diverse suppliers and also frankly
a lot of women and people of color
leaving very prominent spots in the
workforce so here now to talk about this
issue how to bring change from the top
down is natasha lam she's partner
managing partner and co-founder of
arjuna capital a sustainable and impact
investment firm natasha thank you for
being here you've
really waged so many interesting
campaigns pushing for changes at the
biggest companies in the world can you
bring us inside some of the most
interesting campaigns that you've had
when it comes to pay equity
thank you so much for having me happy to
be here this morning and continue this
conversation
i think it's a really important one um
we actually spearheaded an investor
campaign on pay equity going back to
2015
and started pressing the companies in
our portfolio to disclose and close pay
gaps across race and gender and when we
started that work uh no companies were
releasing data on these gaps and what we
understood
is that um
you know if you're not paying women and
people of color fairly um you're not
going to pull from 100 of the talent
pool attract and retain top talent
um and really have a competitive
business you know we started working
with the tech firms the wall street
banks the big retailers um and and it's
a huge issue there and over the years i
mean we've now
as a firm um have successfully pressed
25 companies um to disclose their pay
gaps across race and gender
uh and you know and we're still doing
that even a couple weeks ago we had a
vote go
um
to disney's annual meeting asking for uh
pay equity reporting pay gap reporting
got a nearly 60 percent vote of
investors uh which was the largest vote
in the company's history um and a very
rare uh majority vote for investors so
uh continuing to press companies on this
issue natasha you mentioned disney which
i think i think is pretty interesting
because they've been in the news a lot
for some of their workplace conditions
and their pay how do they stack up in
terms of the things that you are
analyzing and what are some of the other
companies
that you're taking a look at
sure um yeah i mean disney gets an f and
you've probably heard
among some other criticisms but they've
had a lot of litigation on pay equity in
california um
it's clearly been an issue for the
company uh and but you know the fact of
the matter is disney's not alone you
know i i'm sure there's
there are very
few companies uh that have no pay gaps
um particularly when you're looking um
on a median basis and the definition of
the pay gap um is you know what are
women paid versus men on the median it's
83 cents in this country um what are
people of color paid versus their white
um you know white peers um
black workers in this country are paid
64 cents on the dollar uh and and what
we're really pressing for is
transparency
and publishing those gaps and closing
and narrowing them over time so you know
here you've got disney getting an f uh
we actually saw meta or facebook fall
two full letter grades we put out an
annual score card every year um looking
at these this disclosures we just put
out our fifth uh score card on equal pay
day meta fell two full letter grades
because they stopped publishing
quantitative data during the pandemic
and you know gosh that's you know the
pandemic was such a one-two punch for
women and people of color who suffered
80 of the job losses in 2020
that's the wrong time to stop publishing
uh and really managing this data um and
only of of the companies that we that we
scored uh that was 57 companies only
seven
received a grades and that was um pfizer
uh which is you know kind of fitting uh
given the pandemic they they hit the top
mark uh and then mastercard bank of new
york mellon starbucks adobe american
express and citigroup all of whom we've
worked for and worked with and pushed uh
to publish these disclosures natasha
it's interesting you know some of those
companies that i spoke to one thing that
they mentioned to me is that some of the
greatest pressures coming from
washington rather than from investors
where are you seeing the greatest
pressure come in terms of changing the
company's behavior
so you know as i said when we started
this work we weren't seeing any data be
published um being published and
we
a couple of years in the united kingdom
started mandating public disclosure of
median pay gaps um which did apply
pressure um even on u.s companies
because they had to publish pay camps
for their uk operations and you know
we've since said okay you're publishing
it for the uk you're showing big gaps
you need to do that for your global
operations um there have been
uh you know some mandates to public to
share data with the government
that data is not public um so it's
certainly not helpful for investors
because we can't see how companies are
stacking up um and what we know from
some of the studies is that if this data
is public if there's transparency if
there's an honest accounting then
companies actually manage
it more you know you you you manage what
you measure basically we all know that
old adage um but you know even going
back a few years ago there was a white
house uh pay pledge um and companies all
you know sort of ran to sign up and you
know the problem with that is it just
gave them cover oh we signed this pay
pledge but investors their employees
still didn't know um what pay gaps
looked like at the company and if they
were narrowing over time it's all about
uh disclosing it you cannot just pick
play uh lip service natasha lam managing
partner and co-founder of arjuna capital
thank you so much natasha for your time
uh definitely seeing some improvements
there but a lot more to go yeah a lot
more to go and honestly as much as
improvements we are seeing companies
fall behind so holding people
accountable here right that's what we do
here at quick take but that'll do it for
a quick take this hour uh there's more
quick take coming up in just a minute
i'm jennifer zabasanja and i'm sonali
basic you can check out the latest
stories at bloomberg.com or at quicktake
on social media thanks for watching
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
shirt
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
the white picket fence space for
entertaining acres of land to call your
own these were characteristics of the
american dream home
but is it still a dream worth chasing
[Music]
should you buy a home or rent we're here
at the white house at six woods lane in
east hampton long island you could own
this place for the list price of 12.5
million dollars with a 30 year fixed
rate mortgage at 3.991
interest you'd pay nearly 47 000 a month
and that's not including closing costs
home ownership insurance or property
taxes now this kind of place might be a
little pricey for you but the same
principles apply at much lower levels
when you're considering whether to rent
or buy a home now before i break
something in here let's get back to the
studio
[Applause]
to buy or not to buy
that is the question
we pulled our youtube audience and they
had a lot to say one person said owning
a house should not be thought of as an
investment more like something between
an asset and a liability someone else
shared a pretty common sentiment these
days that student loans would prevent
them from ever buying a home another
said abolish private property altogether
but okay a majority of you think
ownership is the way to go and who can
blame them
people think of buying a home as part of
the american dream the driver of middle
class wealth a sound investment vehicle
renting a place is less romantic
throwing money away every month on a
place to rest your head and keep your
stuff but that calculus is changing to
help us run down the reasons why you may
want to rent and not buy i spoke to
financial planner roger ma
[Music]
so can you tell me why renting is not
throwing your money away
well i think the flip side is why is
buying not wasting money and i think
that's a myth that when you buy a lot of
your money is building equity but that's
just not the case your monthly payment
and the upfront and the back end costs
of buying are wasted money as well sure
you've got mortgage interest homeowners
insurance property taxes
potentially homeowners association fees
yeah not to mention the the huge closing
costs on the front end and the back end
if you don't plan to stay in the same
area for at least five years it probably
makes more sense to rent and that's
because of those large closing costs
right you need to give your home
a sufficient amount of time to
potentially increase in value feel like
the generation now growing is maybe more
likely to be on the move definitely
between the ages of 22 and 40 the
average person changes jobs every one to
two years so they're they're changing a
fair amount so
i think having the flexibility to change
jobs could be reasons to rent instead of
buy right and that's okay
there's no shame in renting and if you
look around the united states depending
on where you live it might actually be
more affordable atom data solutions
publishes a yearly affordability index
of buying versus renting and in most
places 59
to be exact real estate prices are
outpacing rentals in fact in all 18 of
the most populous counties in america
it's more affordable to rent than buy
let's be real for a lot of people the
choice of renting verse buying may not
even be yours especially if you're young
i talked to bloomberg reporter patrick
clark about the unique problems facing
potential homebuyers let's talk about
the unique uh hindrances that maybe new
home buyers might face there's not
enough homes they can afford right sure
that would be a big problem at the very
most basic there's an affordability gap
a decade after the foreclosure crisis
we're still building homes not just of
where they were at the peak bubble
madness but still below the number of
new homes that we were adding in like
the mid 90s the construction that is
happening has been skewed towards the
high end that is sort of pressured on
the other side by maybe age
people growing older and maybe not
moving out of their homes there's two
different ways you could get listings or
you could build new homes or you can
have homes that were already occupied
right hit the market there's some
question of whether people want to stay
in their own homes and quote unquote age
in place
[Music]
older people staying in their homes
longer is an issue so there's some
gridlock in the housing market this
generation is now saddled with more um
more kind of burdens than previously was
the case like way more there's like more
than 1.5 trillion dollars of student
loan debt outstanding
yikes the deck is certainly stacked
against this generation
but that long-standing elusive goal of
homeownership seems so tempting all in
all i'd have to put it this way if you
have your heart set on home ownership
nobody's going to stand in your way but
you probably don't need to sweat it too
much either if you don't
that was probably expensive
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat tune in
to watch those who shape our world
explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
are you self-employed
freelancing
do you have a side hustle
all of these are various types of
independent contracting that together
make up what's become known as the gig
economy
three in 10 americans work a gig job of
some kind or another and for many
freelancing is synonymous with freedom
but freedom isn't free there's a lot of
instability that comes with the gig
economy it's a hustle it's a grind you
don't have that safety net of a salaried
job basically working from paycheck's
paycheck this is good money and we're
here to help you run the business of you
okay so the gig economy is a broad topic
so let's separate it into two sections
there's the career freelancer and the
side hustler and let's start with side
hustling because i'm a humble video
producer and i could use some extra
scratch but will i get in trouble with
my company for doing that i wish there
was somebody i could talk to about this
hey uh
you gotta say i can help you out with
this who are you my is mark kohler i'm
just sitting over here reading my own
book on the very topic you're talking
about oh yeah sure
will i get in trouble with my company if
i want to start a side hustle generally
not unless you're going to try to start
a small business in your industry nine
times out of ten you're going to be fine
you can go out and do whatever you want
once you are a side hustler you're
basically a small business yeah yeah a
lot of people don't realize if i'm just
even driving for uber you're getting a
1099 baby that's a small business let's
take advantage of it and the tax
write-offs could be phenomenal yeah sure
tell me about this well under the new
tax cuts and jobs actors we got what's
called the 20 pass-through
we've got cell phone home office
computers electronics travel auto all
these little things that you might be
paying for anyway i call them personal
conversion expenses so what happens if
my side hustle becomes so successful
that uh you know it's cutting into all
my time well congratulations now you've
graduated to career freelancer you're a
full-time business owner it's better to
quit your job now and make more money at
home
you know what
i quit
[Music]
wait a second
was that a good idea what about my
vacation time my 401k my health
insurance and that discounted gym
membership i never signed up for
freelancing seems like a lot more work
than a staff job mostly because you have
to do everything yourself
i'm going to need some more guidance
before i call myself a career freelancer
and what better place to seek advice
than the freelancers union
so let's head to their hq and talk to
executive director caitlin pierce
let's say i just became a career
freelancer what can i do to feel as
secure as i did as a staffer you know
when people are thinking about whether
or not to become a freelancer i always
say before you make that leap think
about a couple of things one is you know
what is your plan for earning enough
income not just to support yourself but
also to take on the additional costs of
managing your tax burden paying for your
own health and benefits and having a
savings plan for retirement
should i be hiring somebody to
do my taxes for me short answer yes one
of the things all freelancers need
especially if they're doing this
full-time is someone that can help you
understand what you can deduct for your
business
and make sure that you've done your
taxes properly so you don't end up with
a liability at the end of the year could
you give me a few financial tips that
help freelancers remain secure first of
all every freelancer needs to have a
good contract that they've worked with a
lawyer and that they understand that's
going to protect their work and make
sure they get paid on time secondly
you should have a system by which you
are automatically setting aside 30 of
your income into taxes as soon as it
comes in before you can touch it and if
you can also setting aside income in
short-term and long-term savings the
third thing i think is that you should
really set aside 10 of your time for
long-term planning and that should
include business building activities
like client prospecting networking
investing in training or upskilling and
it's really important for you to have a
vision for where you're going think
about where you want to be in five years
financially and professionally and be
making steps towards working towards
those goals
so that should get all you freelancers
and side hustlers off on the right foot
as for me
i'm gonna go beg for my cushy staff job
back
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
ah retirement i could spend every day
just like this relaxing playing golf
spending time with family
but like most of you i can't retire
right now or
really anytime soon
work work
work work
work work
so even if we can't retire right now
there are more than a few people who
made their early retirement dreams come
true no lottery ticket or well-timed
crypto investment required those people
are part of a community called fire
that's financial independence retire
early fire devotees combine high savings
rates minimalist living and investing
with low-cost index funds to reach
retirement in relatively short periods
of time
i talked to a guy named bryce lung who
along with his wife christy retired in
their early 30s and never looked back
we were given the same prescriptive
script that everybody uh that our
parents gave us for how to live get a
job buy a house go into debt go into
mortgage spend the next 25 years paying
off and then maybe when you're 65 then
you can retire with a pension the old
rule book that they played with simply
doesn't apply for us anymore so how long
was your journey once you began nine
years after we started working we
retired my wife was 31 i was 32 at the
time and we said goodbye to our jobs
forever and we've been traveling ever
since it's actually based not on your
age but how much money you have saved up
versus how much money you need to spend
to maintain your lifestyle so the rule
that we use in the fire community is
called the four percent rule how much
you have saved up versus how much that
you need to spend if it's four percent
of it then that you can retire safely
and never need to work again why is that
number four percent an academic study
called the trinity study in which they
kind of back tested
um like all of the stock market history
of like going back like hundreds of
years four percent is the amount that
it's safe to withdraw in that uh you
won't run out of money over like a
traditional retirement period how did
you change your lifestyles so that you
would live more frugally there was not
so much a sacrifice of lifestyle that
got us here it was avoiding the
landmines that so many people step on
the commonly accepted personal finance
thing of like you have to cut back until
it's painful no no going out no no
eating uh out and no drinking coffees
and this kind of stuff we didn't do any
of that kind of stuff because the
biggest line items in a person's life is
housing transportation and food and if
you get those three right then the rest
of it almost doesn't even matter but
even if you can't retire at 31 like
bryce did there might still be some
alterations to your savings or spending
that you can make to retire at a more
traditional age bloomberg reporter
suzanne wooley is going to tell us how
to plan for that more traditional
retirement and the annoyances that we
must overcome to get there should people
be scared about retiring
isn't everyone scared about retiring
it's this so big a prospect and it's
also uncertain
and i think people get sort of terrified
by the idea of like what is my number
like do i need a million do i need two
million like who knows and i think that
can put people into paralysis a lot of
people don't even know
how much they spend each month so
you know just knowing what your budget
is gives you a sense of like what you
need to live on what mistakes are people
making uh as they plan for retirement
one mistake people might make is not
planning for contingencies you know you
have like a point when you want to
retire like some people say oh i want to
retire when i'm 62 or 65. well great but
you know life might not go your way you
might be laid off there might be some
sort of ageism you might get sick and
not be able to work so it's sort of when
you're retirement planning you need to
think through like how would i
live if i had if i was laid off you know
five years earlier than i anticipated
and also you need to have some sort of
like emergency fund maybe like buckets
one is for short term and it's just cash
like a year's living expenses if you can
do that you know the middle one is maybe
in
bonds and short-term investments and you
know the other part can be aggressive
the other bucket is more aggressive
really long-term like 10 or 20 years
so if you want to get your fire dream
started go ahead and make it happen as
for me i'm going to do this for a few
more hours then get back to work
turn the camera off
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hey it's henry so this is the last
episode of our season and
it turns out we have some extra money in
the budget and i want to spend that
money on myself so for this episode
we're going to figure out how a person
in this case me can spend money to
increase their own happiness
now i know what you're thinking money
can't buy happiness and you're right
sort of
studies have found that while having
more money greatly affects the happiness
for people living in poverty once
someone earns around 75 dollars a year
the amount of happiness they get from
additional funds flattens out so someone
who makes on average two hundred
thousand dollars a year isn't
necessarily that much happier than
somebody who makes a middle-class salary
like me
so it's kind of unbelievable to hear
that you know me doubling my salary
wouldn't make me any happier but while
more money doesn't necessarily mean more
happiness how we spend our money does
and like any good reporter i did a
google search and watched a ted talk on
happiness by this man dr robert
waldinger he's the director of the
harvard study of adult development a
study that started in 1938 and continues
until this day making it possibly the
longest study of human happiness ever to
have been conducted
we found that many of the things we
expect to predict well-being do like
taking care of yourself taking care of
your health not smoking not abusing
alcohol okay exercising but the surprise
was
that
the quality of our relationships with
other people actually keeps us healthier
and keeps us alive longer
so we looked at their cholesterol we
looked at their blood pressure at age 50
and we looked at their marital
satisfaction
and what we found was that their marital
satisfaction was by far the strongest
predictor of what they were going to be
like when they were 80. marital happiest
marriages at 50 predicted
better health and happiness at age 80.
but to be able to predict across 30
years that's a big deal that begins to
get at causation so relationships it's
like it's like exercise in a way
you don't just do it one week and then
you're done right that relationships
have to be tended to so your marriage
your friendships they take work they
take constant attention over time or
they wither away so how can i buy good
relationships
well you can't
but
that
is a question you should ask of the
researchers who actually study this
luckily these researchers also had ted
talks and have been focusing on that
very question how spending our money
affects our happiness the reason why i
believe it's actually very interesting
to study spending is because it's so
ubiquitous like we all spend and we all
actually have a lot of control over our
spending we are going to spend some of
our money because we have to and are we
really thinking about spending it in
ways that might actually make us happy
and if yes what can we learn as
researchers to help people so there's a
lot of methodology and findings that
come from research done by people like
sandra and michael but i wanted to boil
down some of the biggest takeaways first
off and this shouldn't come as a
surprise but spend money on building
social relationships so there is built
into our close relationships this
element of reciprocity of giving back
and forth what we're trying to do in our
research is say you can do more of it
actually so it's probably not useful to
give someone five dollars and say will
you be a closer friend of mine because
that's not how it works but it does work
to say hey i really like you and i'd
like to take you out to lunch so if you
buy coffee maybe you might want to kind
of spend it on buying a coffee for
yourself and your friend because we know
that if you spend it on someone else you
also gain greater happiness the next big
point is to spend more money on
experiences and less on things
tom gilovich and his colleagues at
cornell for about a decade now have been
doing research showing that
on average buying stuff for yourself
doesn't do much for your happiness
but buying experiences seems to make us
happier what we see when when it comes
to actually buying material goods versus
experiences is that when we buy our
second watch for example we might get
the spike in happiness but at some point
this actually this effect of happiness
goes away and to some extent we might
even regret at some point spending
investing that much money whereas if we
have experiences we kind of go to a
concert there's this effect of
anticipated happiness so we look forward
to going to the concert for two weeks
even like building up to the experience
and then after the experience we can
always go back to it so we have a memory
of the experience we might even share it
with friends come back to it every once
in a while and then when we get together
for for a fun night and finally if
you've been thinking i do want that
apple watch and i know it would make me
happy then good buy it you should know
what makes you happy if people manage to
spend their money in a way that is
aligned with their own psychological
needs and preferences as reflected by
their personality that that seems to be
making people happier if i'm an
extrovert i might be better off spending
my money on going out with friends kind
of having a very social time spending it
on exciting stuff versus like a friend
of mine who's probably more introverted
what they could do instead is spend it
on things that improve their quality me
time so to say the first thing that we
recommend that people do is literally do
an audit of your spending and and what's
important to you is completely up to you
so i can't say these are the things that
should be important to you in life but
you know the things that are important
to you in life and typically when you
look at your spending in this way you
say wow i should really shift some money
from that big category over to this big
category
so to recap the big takeaways in order
to spend money to get happiness first
off know yourself are you an introvert
an extrovert how do you want to spend
your money second use your money to
build social relationships and third put
an emphasis on experiences over things
so if i were to analyze myself for my
money if i'm getting the best return i
am a person who loves my family and i
love sharing experiences with them
around food so i'm thinking i will spend
that extra budget money
you know for the purposes of the show
to take my mom with me to italy and we
have some fantastic meals what are we
looking at
yeah
so it turns out we got like 35 dollars
and 20 cents left in the budget um
so
hey mom
do you want to go to the olive garden
tonight
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artists
and dissident my way away
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to quick take
stock it's the show for retail traders
eager to get smarter i'm katie greifeld
and i'm tim steineveck it's noon on wall
street and between the return of
gamestop as a meme stock kitty would you
say it's up 20 percent right now right
uh it's on its way there yeah it's on
its way there what exactly retail
investors are doing right now and one of
the largest mergers in the cannabis
industry history we've got a lot to get
to so let's get going we start this
morning with the markets equity markets
that is stocks lower today the s p 500
down by about three tenths of one
percent we do see the nasdaq 100
bouncing back a little bit but pretty
much flat right now just up to one
hundredths of one percent the dow jones
industrial average down seven tenths of
one percent the s p 500 has clawed back
about half of its decline since january
and katie speaking of declines today
it's the two-year anniversary of the
coveted bottom for u.s stocks since then
we've seen just a remarkable turnaround
in equities the s p 500 is up more than
100 since then the nasdaq 100 up more
than 108
and the dow jones industrial average is
up more than 87 so katie two years ago
you were here at bloomberg you were
writing about the fed's historic step
into the credit market um what do you
make of the recovery it's pretty
remarkable and i mean this is why buy
the dip works because you know that the
federal reserve pretty much always going
to be there to backstop the markets at
least over the past two years now we're
entering a really
interesting time where i don't know is
the fed going to step in if markets go
to haywire not a big concern today and
this week because you've really seen
markets bounce back very strongly yeah
and one of the companies that is
actually moving today that we wanted to
highlight is general mills seems to have
a little bit of pricing pressure yeah
absolutely pricing power experience
pricing power it's a good thing to have
as inflation is super hot right now so
general mills think cheerios think betty
crocker uh they reported today that they
expect their organic net sales to be
five percent for the fiscal year that
ends in may they also boosted their
outlook in part because they're able to
boost prices that's boosting the stock a
bit you can see shares up two and a half
percent right now but we should also
talk about octa because that's a
different story definitely not doing as
hot so octa it was hacked by a group
called lapses dollar sign tim you and i
were debating how to actually say that
i'm not part of the group not a hacker
yeah me neither no i look at it that's
exactly what it looks like to me lapses
dollar sign so this is interesting
because this is the same group that
hacked microsoft actually this week
microsoft confirmed that uh yesterday i
believe octa also had a data breach as
well and that's hitting shares you can
see they're down about 8.3 even though
you had the likes of morgan stanley
saying that the impact is probably
pretty limited here but you mentioned
gamestop let's talk about game saw
because this stock somehow is on fire
it's up almost 20 percent 19 percent
today that's after eight almost 31
percent gain yesterday and it's a little
bit puzzling there was
some news i mean you do have ryan cohen
saying yesterday that he's boosting his
stake
in gamestop he tweeted i put my money
where my mouth is but
this was after yeah yeah you made the
point shares were already popping
yesterday before that that's why i'm
wondering is it the return of the meme
stock i'm sorry we'll find out i guess
but let's talk more about it uh and
retail investing trends that we've seen
in recent weeks joining us is gina
martin adams she is chief equity
strategist for bloomberg intelligence
also with us is jackson guten plan he's
a senior associate for bloomberg
intelligence and gina help us square
this circle because we've seen a lot of
data over the past few weeks suggesting
that retail investors have kind of faded
in terms of their market impact there
was some interesting data from bank of
america that retail traders were net
sellers last week and yet you have the
likes of gamestop even amc a little bit
uh coming back to the forefront what's
going on
well i think a lot of it is just a
simple lack of confidence it's it's not
just about retail traders sort of
exiting the market as the economy moves
back to normal and some of the stocks
that they were most captivated by
certainly underperforming really since
the spring of 2021
but when we look at overall confidence
levels of the retail investor they've
never been this low at least not since
the low in 2009
and what i mean by that is when we look
at something like the american
association of individual investors
survey of retail confidence
the level of uh retail participants that
are willing to suggest that they're
bullish relative to the level that is uh
that suggests they are bearish has not
been so low since that march 2009 low in
the equity market so retail investors
have lost a tremendous amount of
confidence
part of it is because i think of the
market rotation that we've experienced
over the course of the last year
certainly small caps and some of the
higher volatility higher beta names
across the indices here in the u.s had
been underperforming and underperformed
substantially
up over the course of the last year and
that certainly took out a lot of retail
investors but i think they're also you
know simply worried about the broader
economic climate broader about worried
about you know broadening geopolitical
risks inflation pressures and the like
certainly concerned about the fed
increasing interest rates as well
jackson come on in here and give us an
idea of what you're seeing on the
institutional side and how what what
gina says is perhaps not necessarily
mashed or is matched by what
institutional investors are doing
yeah i actually largely agree with what
gina is saying we're seeing a
significantly lower retail participation
so far through 2022 certainly the lowest
since the onset of the pandemic uh and
the reason you know agreeing with what
gina laid out
being that
it's a very different uh very different
market
retail historically has been a lot less
likely to try to trade around and beat
the market regarding
major macroeconomic events and
geopolitical uncertainty we're seeing
that in the trade data flows are much
more
institutional
institutional activity
repositioning portfolios protecting
downsides
and opportunistically uh trying to
capture as many missed pricings amidst
the volatility certainly much more
institutional flow right now than retail
despite the run-ups and game stuff past
couple days well let's stick with
gamestop and just the spiritual
significance of it gina because i was
ready to retire the phrase meme stock
i've been ready to retire for a while
but
could you see a similar phenomenon
happening again similar to what we saw
you know around this time a year ago uh
that you know you did have just this
this combined effort to pump up this
these speculative areas of the market i
mean not just gamestop i also have art
the arc innovation etf in my mind i mean
could we see those again those
speculative more risky parts of the
market come to life as the fed finally
starts to tighten
you could i think it's unlikely in the
near term
mostly because as the fed starts to
tighten they will then move into another
realm of policy tightening with the
balance sheet tightening which does take
a lot of liquidity out of the market in
the very short run
liquidity historically be is one of the
drivers of high volatility stock
performance relative to low volatility
stock performance so
it's pretty unlikely that we get this
sort of massive
spurt in high vol specifically this year
because of that monetary policy
landscape that said
some of these other factors that have
been depressing confidence could
certainly go away or diminish we could
certainly see
some sort of resolution to geopolitical
conflict we could certainly see some
peaking in inflation conditions near
term we could see the economy continue
to strengthen
significantly and income growth rise
significantly more which could certainly
offset some of that tightening liquidity
and improve retail investor confidence
the other thing that i'd say we want to
be on guard for is if the indices at
large ultimately resolve
their recent corrections through
improvement in price performance making
new all-time highs you could generally
see retail investors come back to the
market just because the markets appear
to be to have healed themselves from
what has been one historically bad start
to the year
so there are a lot of things that drive
confidence you know i think that broadly
we want to keep a very close eye on
liquidity and the changes that the fed
this year and just the short run
probably do continue to take the wind
out of sales of confidence at large and
that liquidity provision has been a
really important part of
improving retail participation but it's
not the only factor and i think we want
to keep an eye on a lot of a whole host
of
of things that could certainly change
the confidence levels all right well
speaking of confidence a level jackson
i'm wondering if if you think now based
on the research that you've done the
analysis that you've done is a good
opportunity for for retail investors to
to actually dive back into to equities
right now
um you know that actually might be a
better question directed for gina you
know where equities are gonna go in the
short term or uh long term that's not
really my expertise um i don't know i i
will say that retail activity is really
aided by uh any bull market um
i think any uh you know continuation of
a full market you know the market were
to turn more optimistic so the dip
buyers will be vindicated more
traders will come back in and you will
likely see marginally higher retail
activity um
what the market is going to do in in the
near term
who's to say
uh one last question for gina jackson um
and you can feel obviously feel free to
weigh in too but this note really just
getting my attention today gina you said
that u.s stocks appear to have priced in
mid staggeration for for 2022. using the
the s word here the stagflation the
concern about you know low growth and
and high inflation here um
where do you think that the pricing in
is happening and and where do we go from
here
yeah so what we did in this note is
really just run the current dynamics of
the macro economy and shock our broader
fair value model for the s p 500 with
some pretty extreme conditions to try to
get a sense for you know how should the
s p 500 be priced in an environment
where
inflation remains extremely high maybe
oil prices even go to 150 per barrel the
fed keeps tightening interest rate
policy but ultimately that 150 per
barrel oil price degrades the growth
outlook sort of trying to to get a sense
for some of the more popular things that
have been kind of running through the
narrative of the equity market over the
last couple of weeks how do they really
impact price
and what we found was even in a pretty
extreme condition of quote unquote
stagflation in which you have prices
remaining very hot with 150 barrel per
oil
150 dollars per barrel of oil and you
have an increase in the unemployment
rate
stocks have already priced
much more
uh downside than even though those sort
of macroeconomic conditions would
produce right and then what i mean by
that is when we saw the equity market
drop on nearly 15 from peak to trough we
priced a tremendous amount of risk
so you've got to actually see economic
conditions really deteriorate more than
our model would anticipate you've got to
see oil prices really surge and stay
there for an extremely long period of
time
in order for stocks to even go lower
from those the lows that we made earlier
this year i think it's one of the
explanations for why stocks are starting
to sort of melt their way higher
is we priced for a tremendous amount of
risk now we have to see those risks
actually evolve
or get worse for stocks to see that next
downlink
well there you have it bloomberg
intelligence is chief market strategist
gina martin adams senior associate
jackson gutton plan big thank you to
both of you for taking the time and
joining us on quick take stock i
appreciate it well coming up we are
talking with the ceo of a cannabis firm
on the verge of one of the industry's
biggest deals we're talking two billion
dollars here you're streaming quick take
stock
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's take a look at pot sales because
bloomberg news broke the story on one of
the largest deals to hit the industry so
far cresco labs is buying columbia care
for 2 billion which will turn it into
the largest multi-state operator in the
u.s now this is a market that has been
on the rise and it's projected to keep
growing market tracker bdsa is
forecasting the u.s cannabis market will
top 50 billion dollars in the next five
years from less than 30 billion in 2021
so currently 37 states and washington
d.c allow some sort of marijuana use
joining us now is charlie backtel he is
the ceo and co-founder of cresco labs
which has 16 buys one hold and zero
sales recommendations and charlie let's
just start with the news of today why
columbia care why does this fit into the
cresco labs mission
yeah you know great question thank you
very much for having us today a very
exciting day
this is a it's a transformative
announcement not only for our
organizations but for the industry uh
why columbia care
you know what we have here is we have
sort of this matching up of two very
complementary organizations where we
have
specialized and shown our ability to
create the number one brand portfolio in
the industry
and also be the most productive retailer
on a per store basis matching up with an
organization that has a tremendous
footprint
that includes uh all the very very
influential legacy markets all of the
states that you want to be in today plus
all of the states that you want to be in
for tomorrow with uh with incredible
growth opportunities
charlie
what are the and i i hate to use this
term because it's something that we hear
executives say a lot uh synergies the
idea of overlaps between the two
companies how can you be more efficient
as a larger company like this do you
have more buying power when it comes to
actually buying products and you can put
more leverage on suppliers where the
synergies here
actually from
the scale that the uh that the combined
organization will have and what we see
is uh significantly higher margins in
states where you've been able to create
scale and where you have that depth of
market uh you know we we loved the
economic diversity that this really is
going to bring to our platform as a
combined entity where we'll have in 2023
we'll have eight different states
that'll be contributing at least a
hundred million dollars to our revenue
right now i think most of the operators
that are in our space have a pretty high
concentration uh two main two or main
three states that are responsible for 75
plus percent of the revenue this will
definitely diversify us as going forward
so again that scale that it creates the
depth in those markets the ability for
us to increase margins that way and also
de-risk the organization through that
diversified revenue stream
and charlie this is a show for retail
investors so i do want to talk about the
stock price a little bit because if i
look at cresco shares they're actually
down 54
over the past year even with all those
buy recommendations zero cell
recommendations i mean what do you think
the market is missing when it comes to
the cresco story
yeah i don't i don't know that the
market is missing much as it relates to
the cresco story that that that uh that
that that uh price uh action that you
mentioned is actually average for the
sector so the sector itself has seen
tremendous declines uh year over year
and really what it is is it's the the
retail investor that is is waiting for
federal reform to occur and and some
fatigue that's associated with it but
you know the way that we look at that is
it's a matter of when not if i think
everybody's on board with that our our
duty our our job right now is to
continue putting the pieces in place for
long-term leadership in this industry
and execute and uh and that
inevitability of the catalyst of federal
reform will come again a matter of when
not if uh well so so what does that look
like charlie and and i mean i have to
ask uh when because if it's what it's
when not if this is a story that
you know we've been talking about for
years at this point and we were
expecting some sort of federal
legislation but look at how slowly the
federal government has moved and there's
this patchwork of regulations that
companies like yours have to navigate
state by state when does that become
easier
you know it's a great question um but
when it comes to politics uh it's it's
something that i've i've heard uh
throughout my my time in cannabis over
the last eight nine years sometimes good
policy doesn't make good politics but
what we are seeing here over the last 12
months especially with this
administration as we enter and get
closer to midterms is good where you do
see good policy make good politics this
is one of the most popular issues in
america so
we've had more momentum
discussions at the highest level of the
federal government than we've ever had
on this topic so again optimistic
more likely than not that we see
something in the near future
but again in the interim it's head down
putting the pieces in place for
long-term leadership and executing
charlie um you told our colleague
tiffany tiffany carey who covers the
industry uh this uh the following which
really stuck out to me after this
acquisition you said this is how you
turn brands like high supply cresco and
floracal into miller high life coca-cola
and johnny walker blue label easy to say
but but not so easy to do
how do you turn your brands and the
brands that you'll be acquiring into
household names
yeah it's it's a great question but this
this goes to the thesis of our
organization from the very beginning you
create the most strategic uh geographic
footprint that you can and you get
meaningful material market positions in
each of those states right so you get
your product on the shelves of the most
important states possible now so you
start building that relationship with
the consumer and you can see cresco's
been more effective than others
creating the you know we're the company
with the number one selling flower
portfolio number one selling vape
portfolio number one selling concentrate
portfolio in the industry now you match
that up again with this footprint that
we talked about earlier and we have
access to over 70 percent of the
addressable cannabis market as this
industry continues to grow um and great
you know as a combined company right now
as number one market share number two
market share and five of those markets
so it's that it's the strategic
footprint and it's really executing in
those markets getting meaningful
material market share well let's stick
with that footprint and how you plan to
expand because this deal it expands your
reach to 17 states that's up from 10
including dc
and i can see in the article so this
will also give you the top market share
in illinois pennsylvania colorado and
virginia what other states do you have
your eye on to expand into
yeah i i could tell you that with this
uh combined footprint we've checked the
boxes
so really you know we'll spend the next
uh you know nine to 12 months here
working through uh the regulatory
processes to to make the combination
come to fruition um but again that's
what we loved about this transaction was
the reach the access to the markets that
matter today and the markets that matter
most tomorrow uh our ability to execute
as we've shown through you know the
ability to gain market share when we're
in markets and they had a they had a
phenomenal infrastructure already in
place with with wonderful team members
and and operations that are going to fit
really nicely into this combined
platform uh so so what's next katie
asked about expansion but i'm wondering
in terms of acquisitions if you've got
your uh your your targets uh your site
set on other targets
look we'll we'll be we'll be observant
and opportunistic but i could also tell
you we have quite a quite a big lift
ahead of us to digest this um it's not
easy as you mentioned on a
state-by-state basis with regulatory
structures uh we're
we're laser focused on making sure that
we get this transaction across the
finish line become the leader in
cannabis at a critical time to become
the leader in cannabis and really follow
through on this for the benefit of all
stakeholders and our shareholders
cresco labs co-founder and ceo charlie
bachtel charlie thanks so much for for
joining us really great to have you on
the program especially on a day we know
you're busy with the acquisition news we
got much more quick take stock coming up
in just a minute we come back we are
talking nfts keep it here
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elise shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
[Music]
why is cinema chain investing in gold do
you remember amc it was a big meme stock
last year the market capitalization
jumped from about four billion dollars
to more than 30 billion dollars in the
space of just a few weeks well the ceo
adam aron has just announced plans to
invest about 30 million dollars in a
gold mine and it says something quite
interesting about how he perceives his
own company's prospects you see the role
of ceo is often to do with capital
allocation in other words how you spend
your investors money in a way that will
generate the best possible returns for
them and usually you can do one of three
things you can either invest in the
existing business by opening new
locations investing in innovations
adding new headcount you can think about
acquiring a company that
will then play well with your existing
companies and the two firms work better
together than they would on their own
and thirdly you can just return that
money to investors now he's not opting
to do any of those things
returning money to investors would be a
strange choice because he only raised on
them last year and besides
amc trades at a considerable premium to
its competitors so it's not necessarily
buying shares at a reasonable price
when it comes to investing in
adjacent deals or the existing business
he's sort of telling investors that i
can't find a way of generating as good a
return as i could by investing in this
gold mine in other words the implicit
suggestion is cinema business is not
very good and you should put your money
elsewhere he's just cutting out the
middleman and doing it himself
and a big thank you to quick takes alex
webb for reporting on that of course
amc's investment in a gold mine
announced just last week katie we
started our program this uh this
afternoon talking about where you and i
were two years ago because today is the
two year anniversary of the uh bottom of
the u.s equity market right during the
covid pandemic and since then the s p
500 is up a whopping 100 we're not even
at all-time highs by the way and it is
amazing that it ended like or right now
we are perfectly on that 100 percent uh
it's just really satisfying first of all
tim happy anniversary anniversary where
i was two years ago i was at my parents
house in new jersey and i was looking at
the story that i wrote this time two
years ago and the headline was fed's
historic step into the credit market may
cure etf dislocations it didn't it did
yeah that's the thing because the fed
not only did it take interest rates
straight to zero but it started buying
corporate bonds it's never done that
before and i think what's really
interesting now is we're dealing with
sort of the opposite problem right and
trying to unwind the fed's balance sheet
raise interest rates after they've been
historically low for such a long period
of time and really understand the
implications of that after seeing
consumer demand bounce back so quickly
we'll see where we are in two years
hopefully and it's continuing in a
better place that is it for quick take
stock more tomorrow i'm tim stenoveck
and i'm katie greifeld we'll see you
tomorrow
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
five hundred
sixty seven thousand seven hundred and
fifteen
that's how many homeless people the u.s
department of housing and urban
development counted on a cold january
night in 2019. more than half a million
americans are homeless on any given
night but on the west coast the problem
has grown worse in recent years things
haven't improved with the kova 19
pandemic in 2020 homelessness is on the
rise in america san francisco is rushing
to contain a coronavirus outbreak that
hit its biggest homeless shelter the
homeless population in the county is up
13 from last year as the city of l.a saw
a 14 jump homelessness is growing and
governments have done too little too
late
there's no doubt that the homeless are
stigmatized and all too often we
conflate the issue with mental health or
we just blame the victim most people
blame homelessness on the person that
it's they're a bum or they're lazy or
they made bad decisions if homelessness
was a punishment for bad decisions we'd
all be homeless but this is a complex
issue
and no two stories are alike they're
actually
a huge range of forces that often kind
of come together and compound one
another when it comes to how an
individual falls into homelessness but
how did we get here how did a nation
with such wealth and prosperity wind up
with half a million people on the
streets
and more importantly
what can we do about it it really is an
urgent problem and there's no reason
that we shouldn't fix it i zoomed in
with a journalist two non-profit execs
and a formally displaced activist to
better understand the confounding issue
of america's homeless
before we can understand american
homelessness we need to know a little
bit about its origins in america a lot
of scholars look to the period
immediately following the civil war
as the emergence of homelessness a lot
of veterans were returning from the war
and returning to very overcrowded
you know industrializing cities that
were very short on housing ever since
then there's been a population of people
in america who have not necessarily fit
into the sort of standard economic
narrative fields like logging
fishing
mining
they wouldn't really have what we would
think of as a stable home
many people who were what we would call
homeless actually did have shelter
in places like single room occupancy
apartments and hotels um in what they
would call flop houses in the 1950s and
60s there was at that time urban renewal
in cities so there were just numerically
speaking a lot fewer of these sort of
transitional very inexpensive housing
options a lot of low-income minority
neighborhoods in american cities were
ripped apart a lot of the housing that
existed in those neighborhoods
was also gone you have more
deinstitutionalization of people
experiencing mental illness
starting in the late 70s and 80s
the department of housing and urban
development
is getting defunded to a significant
degree and then just
de-industrialization
and rising economic inequality created a
more
a larger population of people that are
sort of living in extreme poverty
now that of course is a very abridged
version of the history of american
homelessness but the main takeaway seems
to be that there is no one cause of the
problem the reason that people fall into
homelessness is that there's basically a
series of
unfortunate
events that
befall them
some of those include losing a job they
include domestic violence that's a
leading issue for women in particular
and families returning from war and
experiencing post-traumatic stress
losing benefits whether healthcare or
welfare
having a health problem that costs a
huge amount of money and bankrupts
somebody if you mix one of those things
or you know add multiple of those forces
together
add in addiction or mental health issues
while a multitude of factors can and do
contribute to homelessness
what it really boils down to is right in
the name
homes
the truth is the leading cause of
homelessness is the lack of affordable
housing people are not earning enough
money
to pay for the housing that's available
essentially
there are approximately 11 million
low-income renters in america research
from the federal reserve found that 59
of americans are one paycheck away from
being homeless for every 10 of the
lowest income renters there's fewer than
four apartments that are affordable to
them and so because there's such a
shortage we have nearly eight million of
the lowest income renter households
families who are paying at least half of
their income towards their rent and many
are paying much more they're paying 60
70 80 of their income just to keep a
roof over their heads
so it's sort of like a game of musical
chairs
you have the chairs the chairs are
getting pulled away and they're just
more people than there are chairs to sit
in
coven 19 has proven to be the straw that
broke the camel's back for many of these
struggling households i would say that
covet 19 has exacerbated the underlying
crisis of affordable housing and the
tremendous racial disparities in who is
most harmed by the housing crisis
when you have such limited income to
begin with and you're paying so much of
it to keep a roof over your head
you're always one financial shock
away from missing rent and potentially
facing eviction and in worst cases
becoming homeless
so for many of these same households the
coronavirus is that financial emergency
they've lost jobs they've lost hours at
work they've lost wages it's harder than
ever for them to cobble together what
they need to make rent
a columbia university economist
predicted a 40 to 45 increase in
homelessness by the end of 2020.
this is due to both the newly displaced
as well as the strain kova 19 has put on
existing homeless communities
covet has had definitely had an effect
on the homelessness system shelters have
had to follow the cdc guidance on social
distancing so
they've essentially had to decompress or
thin out their shelters they can't serve
as many people often they're serving
half the number of people that they used
to serve
but there is a silver lining here coven
19 while devastating has demonstrated
what's possible when we mobilize to help
the most vulnerable among us
there's also now a lot more
creative thinking
around what to do to create more housing
and more opportunities for safe places
for homeless people to to stay
there's been more of an embrace of
sanctioned encampments which are
essentially
places where
local governments set up security and
bathrooms and facilities to help
and then allow homeless people to come
the other big thing is hotels were
emptied out because tourists disappeared
during covid and so a lot of cities
started housing homeless people in in
those empty hotels hundreds of men have
moved from homeless shelters to a fancy
hotel i called the lucerne hotel they
said they are not taking reservations
until at least december it seems like
that was a it's a pretty successful way
to actually prevent mass outbreaks among
the homeless population
one thing the coronavirus has shown is
that governments if they want to can
work with homeless service providers and
increase the urgency and create programs
to get people off the streets
but clearly
we as a country
are not doing enough
we can end homelessness we actually
know how to end homelessness and we've
known how to end homelessness for a long
time the problem is there's not the
public and political will to push all
the policy change forward
to create more affordable housing and to
create
programs in support of housing to get
homeless people off the streets in the
numbers that we need to get them off the
streets to end homelessness
i think there is a widespread sense
among people who work in homelessness
services that there isn't enough money
devoted to this and the the top
line answer is that
it's such a big and complicated problem
that there are several levers that need
to be pulled from a policy perspective
there's generally
bipartisan understanding that we have a
homelessness crisis that is unacceptable
there's generally a bipartisan
understanding that we have a shortage
of affordable apartments for the lowest
income people where there tends to be a
split is
whether there's a willingness to fund
the investments that are needed to
alleviate the problems
the major way that you're going to end
homelessness by getting people into
housing as quickly as possible and since
these are very poor people
and they can't afford most housing we're
going to need housing subsidies to
accomplish that
many many people the majority of people
who become homeless actually do exit
homelessness they get back on their feet
they find a job and they don't enter the
homeless system again and it's not a
long-term lifetime sentence being
homeless so we have to remember that
it's something that for most people is a
shorter term experience
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter you
will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
the tally of death and destruction keeps
growing in the northern california
wildfires thick clouds of ash are
turning day into night
2020 has been another record-setting
wildfire season over the last few years
wildfires have been raging not just in
the western u.s but all around the world
fires in the amazon rainforest and
australia's brush fires are so massive
that they can be seen from space
and while fires have long been a natural
part of many forest ecosystems higher
temperatures and longer droughts caused
by climate change are drying out forests
and turning trees into tinder meaning
that in areas like california wildfire
seasons have become supercharged towns
like paradise california where the 2018
campfire destroyed over 80 percent of
its homes are now grappling with how to
adapt to this new age of fire starting
from essentially the ground up it is
literally like the surface of the moon
there
two years later as a town still works to
rebuild the local parks and recreation
district is beginning an ambitious plan
to not just restore paradise but make
sure it can better defend itself from
the next fire
[Music]
city lab reporter laura bliss went to
see this first hand
so laura you just went to paradise can
you sort of explain what's it like to be
there now it was a pretty haunting
experience just thousands and thousands
of homes literally reduced to shells
kind of gutted out foundations
it really still is this landscape of
disaster
[Music]
so i guess what what has a scale of
rebuilding been like i checked with the
city and there's been about 400 homes
that have already been reconstructed and
about 1200 that are currently permitted
even as this kind of instinct to rebuild
is sweeping over the town and over
former residents there are some people
who are thinking a little bit
differently about what the future of
paradise should look like
one resident i spoke to
has actually gone forward with selling
her land so that eventually it might
become part of a large green belt
encircling the city to potentially
protect it from future wildfires
and the person who's leading this
project is not a member of city
government he's actually the manager of
the paradise recreation and parks
district
my name is dan f i'm the district
manager for the paradise recreation and
park district
so we've provided everything from
swimming lessons to uh people's first
sports experience to hosting a variety
of clubs and we've been a kind of fabric
of the community for decades
there were quite a few lessons from the
campfire for us one of them was the role
we potentially have as a parks district
and dan believes what the park district
can start to do is improve what's known
as the wildland urban interface it's
that line between kind of a full-blown
nature and kind of wildland areas and
then the more developed space
in paradise that line was very much
blurred or a razor's edge
so the idea here is that we would take
that
very narrow razor sharp
wildland urban interface now and expand
it out in such a way that we would have
a buffer at the same time providing
these kind of extraordinary recreational
resources and opportunities dan and the
parks and recreation district are in the
very early phases of acquiring land in
hopes of connecting them and what would
be basically a giant moat of green space
so if the nascent plan is fully realized
thousands of acres of land could be used
for respite and play by the residents of
paradise
parks and baseball fields could also
double as future fuel breaks for fire
so areas that could be parks they could
be
returned in some cases to orchards we're
interested in ag terrorism in the area
so we're trying to do is take this idea
of defensible space around a house and
expand that to the vessel space around
the community
this plant is taking shape now
as california
and all of the western u.s is on fire
already this year millions of acres have
burned
tens of thousands of people have had to
evacuate
with climate change driving up
temperatures and drying out forests
there's no question that the risk of
catastrophe recurring in communities
like paradise and paradise itself is
very very real
but for dan he's hoping that this plan
can make paradise not just a dire
warning of the damage wildfires can
cause but rather a model on how to
better protect communities in fire prone
regions earthquakes we have major cities
all up and down the west coast that
certain major earthquake vaults we've
mitigated that we've engineered our way
into having
less danger associated with earthquakes
in major cities and we can do the same
with fire we just haven't done it yet
this is crystal cold she's a geographer
by training
i call myself a pyro geographer
because almost all of my work over the
last 15 20 years has been across this
really broad spectrum of understanding
how
humans and the environment are affected
by and interact with fire there are a
lot of different factors that contribute
to changing wildfires but climate change
is the thing that amplifies all of those
changes so when we have a high
temperature there's a lot more heat and
that heat translates into fires being
able to burn more easily and because
they're able to burn more easily the
conditions are drier they're able to
burn a lot hotter and a lot faster and
they're much much more difficult for
firefighters to contain
while around the country the number of
wildland fires have actually been going
down since 1990 the acres burned has at
times doubled
the idea in paradise is to use what's
called a green belt to help slow the
destructiveness of future fires
green belts are a type of fuel break
right
green belts are of course these areas
where a lot of the understory is
removed under trees that they become
essentially park-like grasslands
this is one of the jewels of our area
this is paradise lake this was a
location where the fire slowed down and
stopped on its own you can definitely
see evidence of fire through this area
but the flame lengths are relatively low
on these trees look at all of these
small trees that were cut these are cut
before the fire so that created a more
open understory which carried the fire
less than it would have otherwise
dan wants to use the land that they
require to create more areas that look
like this
we are going to pursue a strategy here
to these oaks that are sprouting up make
them less bushy make it less of a brush
field over time and encourage one
particular leader out of here to grow
into a tree it's really important to
note that it's not going to be as simple
as just planting some trees and grass
and hoping for the best
fire breaks are not invulnerable to the
spread of fires
high winds especially the ones we've
seen igniting some of the fires of these
catastrophic events over the last couple
of years
can carry burning embers as far as a
mile
a common misconception that people have
is that a fire break should just stop a
fire right that's that's the definition
right it's meant to break a fire's
forward progress and it should do it all
by itself and that's really a
misconception because that is not what
the goal of a fire break usually is it
is specifically meant to be a safe place
for firefighters to take a stand and try
and modify
fires forward progress as it's coming
into a community
you know i keep thinking about this with
the story that pulling off this green
belt feels like a lot for a parks and
rec district to pull off
how much does something like this cost i
think dan's back of the envelope
calculation was that this is going to
require you know upwards of 10 million
dollars and that's not even including
you know what it's going to take to
maintain all these lands
so just to give you a sense of what this
would entail
one of the sections that dan is
targeting for this green buffer idea is
a stretch of land that runs parallel to
the feather river canyon it's about
seven miles long and about four thousand
acres in total containing hundreds of
properties about eighty percent of that
area is privately owned so on top of the
costs of acquiring the land it's also
just the time and kind of resources that
a little parks district may be
challenged to work up to
turning these former homes into parkland
also hits on the ultra sensitive
question of plan relocation which is
this idea of government basically coming
in to assist whole communities of people
move to an area that's safer from a
climate change perspective
and that's a really difficult question
in a community that's already been
deeply traumatized by this catastrophic
experience
you know we're absolutely
of the mind we have to be respectful of
all our decisions by landowners i think
the idea is right now there's such a
receptivity to people wanting to do some
things that help the community even if
they choose to rebuild then maybe they
will provide an easement or a permission
to have that trail that goes to the
bottom of their property that allows for
fuels reduction protects their property
in exchange for a little bit of
recreational value i think that idea is
pretty persuasive for a lot of people in
our community
another issue dan faces is that while
there is a lot of anecdotal evidence
that green belts can help there actually
isn't that much scientific evidence that
confirms their effectiveness
one conservationist i talked to for the
story referred to green buffers is this
funny combination of common sense with
not a lot of scientific backup but
experts say that the signs are
definitely out there that they can work
it's something that is you know not
really making it into the scientific
literature because it's been relatively
rare we don't have the sort of rigorous
reproducible scientific process that is
often favored by scientific journals
but the anecdotal data are very much
supportive of this i actually published
a study last year about a series of fire
breaks and what was essentially a green
belt around the community of montecito
california between the years of 1999 and
2017 montecito would spend over 1.6
million dollars on wildfire
vulnerability reduction activities and
over years they did it little by little
it's individual properties it's along
roads where they have space to work and
when we actually went back and looked at
the satellite data it looks a little bit
like a green necklace and in 2017 the
thomas fire would put that work to the
test the calmer conditions in santa
barbara county wednesday didn't mean
flames stopped threatening multi-million
dollar homes in montecito this is the
fifth largest fire in california history
and when that fire hit montecito there
were winds blowing over 60 miles an hour
there were gusts up to 72 miles an hour
and that was the last thing we had
recorded before the weather station
burned down and when it got to that
green belt along the edge of the town it
basically did exactly what the green
belt was designed to do which is it died
down it allowed firefighters to move in
close and work safely to put water on
the edge of the fire and actually drop
it down to the ground and put it out and
it is one of the few cases that is
really well documented retrospectively
and spatially of a green belt working
well we're trying to find more of those
but but it's a challenge
what we're talking about is an idea that
how do we live with fire in this
landscape potentially we can serve a
model on a whole bunch of different
levels not just the parks and how to
protect the community but how do we take
care of our people
we can do all the science we want but if
people don't see how it applies to them
and how it can translate into an action
that they can actually take then the
science doesn't actually you know become
applied in any way shape or form and we
don't change actions on the ground
there's been a lot of interest in how do
we protect paradise there's lessons here
we're far enough along that we can
demonstrate some of those lessons to
those unfortunate communities that have
suffered very similar situations but
also
there's models in here that that are
gonna you know
help people live better better lives in
these mountain communities
[Music]
[Music]
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
coming up on quick take for the
estimated 25 of the us workforce who
have seen their work shift to be fully
remote or for those leaving jobs in
search of more fully remote work there's
a new trend that could double your
salary and it's simple work two or
sometimes more full-time remote jobs at
once and in secret my household income
was probably 300 400 000 somewhere there
before and now we're over a million
people think of those numbers as really
big numbers it's not possible i think
this is a mindset thing in a survey
published in october of 2021 nearly 40
of remote workers admitted to having two
full-time jobs
this movement has been dubbed
overemployment and an entire community
has popped up to help navigate their
secret double lives but for both
employers and employees can multiple
remote jobs be a sustainable part of our
future of work
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
for the estimated 25 of the us workforce
who have seen their work shift to be
fully remote or for those leaving jobs
in search of more fully remote work
there's a new trend that could double
your salary and it's simple work two or
sometimes more full-time remote jobs at
once and in secret my household income
was probably
300 400 000 somewhere there before and
now we're over a million people think of
those numbers as really big numbers it's
not possible i think this is a mindset
thing in a survey published in october
of 2021 nearly 40 percent of remote
workers admitted to having two full-time
jobs
this movement has been dubbed
overemployment and an entire community
has popped up to help navigate their
secret double lives with advice like
what you can use to be on two zoom calls
at the same time or how you can avoid
burnout by being mediocre proponents
believe that for some it can unlock both
more money and less stress but for both
employers and employees can multiple
remote jobs be a sustainable part of our
future of work
trends and multiple full-time employment
of course only apply to certain
industries there are of course some
industries like healthcare and
restaurants and travel that simply can't
be remote but with the exception of
those many have the ability to work from
home client-facing roles or jobs that
require in-person attendance can't be
done simultaneously unless they operate
in completely different hours of the day
but that leaves a lot of room for
knowledge workers in sectors like
technology and finance people have
gotten a lot more efficient working from
home and so
that has reduced the working day to some
degree and has probably allowed for
especially software developers for
instance
to work another job perhaps because
they've saved on time recent research
found that 31 percent of tech
professionals admit to putting in just
three to four hours of work a day with
one anonymous facebook employee saying
that they put in less than one hour of
work if you don't factor in all the
hours and meetings a lot of people in
o-employee community are in accounting
finance insurance sales obviously you
know software developers are kind of at
the forefront of the community and then
still is the most remote friendly job
just from a supply and demand reason
this is the voice of isaac he runs the
website overemployed.com a site
dedicated to give resources and promote
the idea of working multiple full-time
jobs and being someone who himself
claims to work two jobs he has asked us
to keep his name voice and image
anonymous overemployed really just stem
from me trying i guess it out myself you
know talking to several different
lawyers looking at my employment
contract and seeking knowledge and and
permission if you will and then i
haven't talked to a family member who
was just you know chuckled at the idea
because and said that she knew many
people that were doing it and it's been
the biggest open secret out that's like
okay
for some it may be surprising to know
that what people like isaac are doing
doesn't necessarily violate any laws
generally speaking there's there's no
law that would prohibit an employee from
having two jobs at once
at most it can be a violation of an
employer policy there are some employers
who have what they call no moon lighting
policies some are a complete ban on
outside employment some say no outside
employment that interferes with your job
duties or conflicts with what you do for
the employer or with the employer's
business nevertheless those who have two
jobs often go to great lengths to hide
that fact i tend to have a very defined
structure on how i structure my days my
day's actually very busy being a dad
that's my number one priority and then i
still work in and kind of 90 minutes you
know sprints i call them or you know
three four of them throughout the day to
focus across you know one job or two job
a job one or job too and get what i need
to get done there one thing is never mix
the hardware if you will keep it
completely separated and stand alone
don't use your employer's property their
laptops computers printers paper
whatever it is to perform work for the
other employer
and don't ever lie about not having the
job because employers can you know fire
employees for dishonesty no matter what
it relates to some companies are
catching on to potential moonlighters
using tools like artificial intelligence
or productivity monitoring software that
can track employee engagement with
various tools like monitoring how much
your mouse is moving during the day
but even for these obstacles the
overemployed community has well
solutions and while technology can help
keep some of these overemployed workers
from legal issues they also need to be
aware of their own mental load
when you're thinking about two jobs and
when you're thinking about the
implications of having two jobs not just
in terms of responsibility but in terms
of the psychological load of having to
lie and having to hide
i think
again it depends on your unique
situation it depends on how hard it is
for you to do that especially when we
know that psychologically when you feel
guilty about something it's like the
pressure of being found out is
can almost be excruciating this is rahav
harfouch a digital anthropologist and
researcher who recently wrote a book on
hustle culture and burnout we're playing
all of this over employment stuff on the
backdrop of a global pandemic of opening
and closing borders we're already pretty
stressed
many of us are already pretty stressed
managing enough uncertainty so if that's
not your personality adding yet another
giant bundle of uncertainty that could
have legal financial reputational
consequences it would just be something
that i would advise that a person would
really think through
because you know the all the money that
you could earn if it ends up tanking
your reputation in industry or having
legal consequences and stressing you out
so you can't even enjoy your time off
those are the hidden costs that we need
to take a look at i think that's a
misconception that people have that that
you know if you do multiple jobs you
must be overworking you don't have to if
you're productive and thoughtful about
how you allocate your time with deep
focus work etc as isaac explains having
two jobs at least in his experience has
actually reduced the stress around his
work i haven't found it stressful but to
each your own one of the nice side
effects of virtual remote work is you
know with two jobs or three jobs or
whatever if you don't like the meeting
you don't have to go to it see what
happens to say decline i can't get the
meeting notes you know if that meeting
was wasting your time it wasn't adding
to your bottom line results that you're
you're tasked to produce
you can stay wide and i think a lot of
the over employer kind of leading
some of the charge and pushing back with
overworking
that a lot of people with one job are
overcompensating actually and
overworking because they worry about
their job and that's why they're the
ones that are like you know going to
meetings 12 hours a day back to back you
know it's a choice that just really
comes down to is a choice of what you do
with your time
and taking that time back is a mindset
shift that is at the core of what the
proponents of overemployment believe
detach yourself from your job don't wrap
your identity into work and strive to
simply meet expectations not exceed them
in our work culture we have the
sociological phenomena called work
devotion which is a set of behaviors
that we all do that we've all done that
signal to our colleagues and co-workers
that we deserve our success so what ends
up happening is their sense of
self-worth
becomes intrinsically linked with how
hard they work with the type of job that
they work and then it's not even about
the job that they have it's about how
hard they're working for that job but
we've actually been seeing research-wise
economically for years is that people
are working really hard there are some
people that are working two and three
jobs not over employment just two to
three jobs in the gig economy part-time
work and still are not able to make ends
meet and so for me i think if you are
going to do this and separate your sense
of self from your job if that's what it
takes for you to say hey i am not my job
title that maybe i want to be present
and joyful and healthy and happy and
have relationships i think that's great
and even if it is possible to work two
full-time remote jobs it likely isn't
going to be for everyone but it does
point to a larger trend happening in
work overall a shifting perspective on
our work life
when the pandemic happened and lots of
people lost their jobs a lot of people
were slow to come back to their employer
or there was just this psychological
shift where they were rethinking the
type of work that they wanted and that
resulted in a labor shortage and so now
people have this power to
negotiate and sort of get the type of
work that they want
as the economy recovers workers have
used this new power to find better
working accommodations in a movement
that some have been calling the great
resignation we really saw this idea of
the great resignation start in the
middle of last year
and this was as unemployment benefits
started to kind of unwind and people
were going back to jobs that they had
before the pandemic but they realized
that the hours were very rigorous for
example or that the work was not
positioning them for the future that
they wanted we've moved away from
40 hours a week at your desk nine to
five
and toward people having more autonomy
over
how they want to shape what their
careers look like long-term and for some
in the over-employed community growing
your income the traditional fashion by
being promoted can look less attractive
for example according to glassdoor.com
the average total pay for a software
engineer is about 156 000 per year at
google and 166 000 per year at meta and
while senior software engineers make
significantly more money it still isn't
as much as having two more junior roles
if you have a full-time job you know you
are
you have one source of income and if
based on continuing economic disruptions
layoffs are becoming more and more
common across industries so does it make
sense for you to devote all of your time
and your extra time into one company
where one day you can come into the
office and suddenly it's like guess what
no more job this has just sort of opened
a door for people to
navigate employment in new ways but it
doesn't necessarily mean people are
going to be able to sustain two three
jobs at a time for many years because as
we mentioned burnout is a real thing and
even if you can do it for
a year or so it doesn't mean you can do
it you know once you've got children or
once you've got other responsibilities
that kind of take time out of your day i
think you're going to find that there
are people that are going to be engaging
in over employment for very different
reasons in very different ways if
there's one thing that we can take away
from over-employment it's this idea that
we have more control over our time than
we think there are things that we
believe to be true about working about
our day-to-day about our calendars about
our relationships with our teams and our
bosses that are the way they are because
we've never questioned them because
that's just how they've always been so
the more interesting thing to think
about is how can i where can i do things
a bit differently where can i explore
new ideas or try new things or
test out new concepts and maybe by doing
that you'll start to shift and realize
that your work reality is whatever you
make it
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
the great resignation is continuing to
lose there are more than 11 million
unfilled jobs right now we hear from
businesses all over the country that
it's very hard to hire people
almost two years into the pandemic
workforce participation remains slumped
while job openings are near record highs
and this is coming at a time when the
recruiting process is going through a
radical transformation
companies in the past were maybe getting
dozens of applicants for a single
vacancy now they're getting hundreds
maybe even thousands of applications and
so software has come in to automate the
process of looking through all of these
different candidates if you've applied
for a job in the last five years you've
probably been impacted by this
technology whether it was screening your
resume making you play games to analyze
your personality making you go through
some other automated system
and some people are fighting back who's
accountable when those ai machines break
the law why it's important that congress
take action to ensure that big tech is
held accountable they claim there's
labor shortages but there's a plethora
of people out there who are looking for
jobs we're at a moment of growing crisis
with ai hiring and that's why people are
eager to act
amidst this whirlwind of disruption one
has to ask the question how do we go
from this
to this
[Music]
more than a decade ago instead of just
replying to a job in a newspaper
printing out hundreds of resumes and
sending them out physically to companies
now you can apply to even more companies
all at once by doing it over the
internet if you hate going to work and
your co-workers don't respect you hey
dummy it's probably time you need a new
job companies now they're getting
hundreds maybe even thousands of
applications and so software has come in
to automate the process of looking
through all of these different
candidates effectively using something
called ats or applicant tracking systems
these systems effectively track
different applicants look through their
resumes and take them even potentially
through the whole process they will take
candidates who are at the top the middle
and the bottom of performers as deemed
by a particular company or hiring
company and then train their systems
based on those judgments and then use
that as a baseline on which to make its
own automated judgments about whether
someone is good or bad
not just students experienced
professionals they just they just don't
know that these tools are used so
frequently
gracie sarkisian runs new york
university's career center where she
gives tips to optimize applications for
ai systems students will encounter ai
tools in an interview if they're doing a
virtual interview some folks will also
encounter ai-powered assessments as part
of their interview process depending on
the industries in which they're entering
the use of the software is very
prevalent there was a recent harvard
business study that came out showing
nearly every single one of the fortune
500 companies use this kind of software
large companies are never going to be
able to stop using this they just have
no choice because of the inbound flood
of applicants they get every single day
most vendors position their software as
something that can alleviate the human
bias which has shown to be endemic to
the hiring process
but critics question whether ai is
actually injecting fairness or just
making those same biases more efficient
i definitely think there is a segment of
the population that is being excluded or
not
fully represented
and they are being left to the wayside
this is jamal eggleston he's a work
readiness instructor at the hope program
a non-profit that helps new yorkers find
jobs
my students aren't prepared for it and
coming from the population that might
not be again as familiar with the
technology they run into pitfalls and
they they don't do as well as other
communities when encountering these ai
since u.s companies don't have to
disclose when they're using ai many
applicants are still writing resumes
catered to the human eye rather than to
ai
when people tell you that you should
dress up your accomplishments or should
use non-standard resume templates to
make your resume stand out when it's in
a pile of resumes that's awful advice
the only job your resume has
is to be comprehensible to the software
or robot that is reading it because that
software or robot is going to decide
whether or not a human ever gets their
eyes on it
ian siegel runs ziprecruiter one of the
dozens of ai companies which transform
the job hunt in recent years
you want to write your resume for robots
not for humans these software's not only
review them to decide who gets passed to
a human but another thing they do is
they write simple summaries of who you
are for those humans so that those
humans may in fact never see your actual
resume
and it's not just resume screening
that's changed initial job interviews
and assessments are being automated at
companies like goldman sachs delta
airlines and walmart
this screen may look familiar you have a
minute or two to answer questions or
play an assessment game which will
determine whether or not you move on to
the next round
so we decided to try out one of these
systems for ourselves talk about a time
when i was overwhelmed or stressed they
had an employee who um's working style
and my management style were not in sync
all right playing the first game it's
kind of like a remembering memorizing
four
six
seven and you have to okay so it's like
pattern recognition
okay
maybe i'm not getting the job i don't
know how much this is going to tell
about a
person what okay your assessment has
been submitted please click the button
above to continue
[Music]
while our tests were unscored many
companies algorithmically rank
interviews based on word choice vocal
tone and facial expression
a lot of people are missing out a lot of
people are not giving back what the
interviewer is looking for because it
was programmed a certain way these
things are programmed by a certain
segment of the population that might not
be totally inclusive or not be fully
aware of how other cultures emote i
believe race is a part of it i know it's
trying to be uh trying to leave race out
of it i know it's trying to be uh not
biased but some things are inherent
even if it's unconscious
i like to call it the ghost in the
machine
in a statement higher view said its
systems are rigorously audited for
adverse impacts meet all regulations and
only analyze word choice
last year the company announced a
discontinued facial analysis in part
over bias concerns
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show first i'll be meeting chinese
artist and dissident ai weiwei and i'll
talk to the novelist and political
scientist elif shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
applicants trying to navigate this new
world of hiring find themselves looking
for help on social media this is how to
be automated resume screening software
here's how to trick the online job
application if you know how to play the
game you're actually able to stand out
on top as the best candidate
one controversial strategy is copying an
entire job description into your resume
hidden with white font in order to trick
the ai into picking up keywords
they won't be able to see that you have
all of those qualifications and is
exactly what they have on their website
because it's all white
it's eventually going to go to a human
being that's going to look at that
resume and say this is ridiculous it's
not about beating the system i think
that that
that thinking is not going to help
candidates to be most successful what
helps you be most successful in the job
search is to know that the world of work
is always changing
there are tech vendors that help
candidates optimize their resume for
systems we have a tool that we use at
nyu other universities use it it's
called vmock students can put their
resume into the system and it will give
them a score and one of the things that
it's scoring for is how likely it will
be to be picked up by an ats for a
particular industry
while elite universities have access to
resume optimizing tech
others may be left behind in this new
world of work there are millions of
people who are being left out of the job
market because hiring software is
discounting them very early on on the
process when it scans their resumes we
have students who some had belts with
incarceration some of our students are
college students some of our students
are long-term workers who have been laid
off because of the pandemic and these
are good people who have great
experiences who can add and become
assets to a lot of these companies for
example a person who perhaps spent some
time in the military
or someone who went on parental leave
might have a year or two long gap in
their resume now if you were going to
interview with a human being you might
be able to explain why that gap is there
but an algorithm doesn't necessarily see
that it just sees that between a couple
of years you weren't working a lot of
times they get no response
and it's really hard because they're
they they don't know what they did wrong
they don't know if they did anything
wrong there's this term the black box of
artificial intelligence what's happening
with some of these algorithms is they
might be discounting hundreds of
different types of people but even the
people who create the software don't
know why
in a statement isims one of the leading
ats vendors said it takes these concerns
seriously and has a team focused on
responsible ai and follows industry
initiatives on fairness
algorithmic discrimination is difficult
to prove but it's been revealed by
audits
amazon scrapped its ai recruitment tool
in 2018 after it discriminated against
applications which listed women's
colleges or sports in another system the
best predictors of job performance
included being named jared or having
played high school lacrosse according to
an auditing law firm the algorithms that
are being used to
look at people's resumes to conduct
interviews they've been trained on data
about previous applicants over perhaps
the past decade that's how machine
learning works
no one explicitly told these systems to
discriminate but they were trained on
millions of biased hiring decisions the
fear with these algorithms
is that you take bias data in because
they're using the wisdom of the crowd
and the crowd is clearly biased and what
you're really doing is perfecting bias
that's the accusation that's been made
the reality is that when we deploy these
algorithms we as the software engineers
and programmers get to make choices
about what data the algorithm can and
cannot use we can say to the algorithm
you never get to see someone's name if i
tell you someone's name is jeremy levine
you know something about them if i tell
you somebody's name is natasha you know
something about them and by removing
them we create the most level playing
field we possibly can so as much as
possible it's a merit-based system
while automated hiring tools have become
ubiquitous public perception hasn't
caught on recent pew surveys found that
most americans didn't know resumes are
being screened by computers and most
considered the practice unacceptable but
one crucial group is paying attention to
ai lawmakers the european union has
unveiled its proposed strategy for
artificial intelligence including
regulations on transparency and data
protection concerns about how this
technology could exacerbate
discrimination for the ftc i think
foremost the ftc needs to be making sure
that we're fully understanding this
technology
a federal civil rights agency is
scrutinizing automated hiring tools
while illinois and dc have explored some
of the nation's first ai hiring
regulations the federal trade commission
recently gave a message to companies
using ai hold yourself accountable or be
ready for the ftc to do it for you in
new york we just enacted one of the
first ai hiring regulations in the
country albert vox khan runs a
technology advocacy group and
participated in new york's task force to
understand the impact of ai systems
the bill basically started off by saying
before you sell this technology you'll
have to do an audit and you'll have to
tell people when this technology has
been used and when you look at what this
bill did
it was regulation name only having an
audit can be useful but when that audit
is done by the software vendor
themselves well that's not worth the
paper it's written on and it's absurd
but in the new york law you can't sue it
doesn't matter how egregious the
software is it doesn't matter how biased
you don't get your day in court and
without that
none of these bills can work
in response some of the world's largest
companies like ibm and facebook parent
meta have devised an auditing standard
for ai and hiring however critics say
that industry standards can't replace
true government i'm scarlet foo and this
is bloomberg quick take the economic
effects of russia's invasion of ukraine
are being felt all over the world
including on american farm fields russia
and ukraine produce over a quarter of
the world's wheat with those exports now
in peril some farmers are looking to
fill that void this in turn is leading
to higher demand for farm equipment so
for more i want to bring in bloomberg
commodities reporter joe doe and joe i'm
kind of understating the situation
because you have noticed that there are
full-on bidding wars for certain farm
equipment right yeah that's right we had
a story that really looked at these
so-called air seeders and without
getting too far into it basically an air
seeder is what plants wheat
it's the machine that they prefer to put
wheat seed into soil and what we found
is
there's bidding on used equipment of
these air seeders going for 450 000
615 000 i mean these are numbers that
machinery pete this is a guy named greg
peterson who's the go-to i love that
name
it's it's pretty unbelievable
unbelievable but he's the go-to industry
source for used farm equipment he said
listen at the end of the year i thought
prices couldn't get any higher for farm
equipment and then the turn of the year
it happened and now we have russia
invading ukraine and it's pretty
uncertain as to how high this could
really go so
it went up to as much as six hundred
thousand dollars how much is a new uh
air seeder you know we were looking at
new air seeder prices for for deer right
we figured that was a pretty good
benchmark um
you're looking at about 350 000 and
that's before you put in all the bells
and whistles so obviously you know the
air seeders the used air seeders we were
looking at are larger ones and you know
they're obviously in pretty good shape
but i think that gives you a good sense
of where the market is right there's
severe constrain in getting new
equipment and that just goes back to the
supply of chain issues that have existed
around the globe now for well over a
year yeah and if farmers are having to
wait one two years to get new equipment
but they need something now that tells
you that they're willing to pay quite a
premium on used equipment that they can
get onto their farms immediately and
that's really important here at that
point that they need to be preparing for
what's going to happen a couple months
or maybe even a couple years down the
road um you cover companies like john
deere and if you look at the share price
it has climbed to record highs because
the war is stoking demand for farm
equipment like you've written about how
is the company responding i mean is it
building more of these air seaters to to
fill this demand so the war obviously
started in uh at the end of february and
we haven't had deer come out and say
anything publicly about the direct
impacts of the war what we do know
leading up to that is the company has
been raising prices
every quarter on all of its equipment
and a large part of raising those prices
and has been going on for a number of
quarters now is to offset the rising
material costs that have been going on
because of inflation and you know to
offset the the shipping and supply chain
problems that we've been seeing out
there
one of the reasons we also looked at
these air seeders for wheat is because
american farmers typically go bigger on
soybeans and corn plantings
and as you said at the top of this this
segment you know russia and ukraine
account for a quarter of
wheat exports to the globe so that means
somebody's going to have to at least
fill in some of the gap that's happened
if we don't actually see that same
amount of wheat being exported from
ukraine and russia
and
we just have some data out some private
data out showing that we're actually
starting to see an increase in the
amount of wheat that american farmers
are planting
versus what they've done in the past so
what does that mean that american
farmers will plant less of because they
only have so much room for plantings if
they're going to increase their
plantings of wheat they're giving up on
something else no yeah i mean it
probably means that they're going to be
producing a little bit less corn and a
little bit less soybean now listen we
don't want to get too far ahead of
ourselves because this is such early
days and that again is not to say that
you know suddenly farmers are not going
to be producing as much corn and soybean
but it does show that at least some
farmers are going out there and saying
you know what we're going to use part of
our crop to focus on
wheat um you know it's
now you know corn and soybean are
typically more profitable uh and
especially if you can get the right soil
in the right conditions um it's it's
just a big game
but obviously some people think
especially with wheat prices rising more
than 30 percent since the war started
yeah they can probably get a nice bit of
profit by planting a little bit of wheat
that they normally wouldn't have done
yeah definitely works out in their favor
so we keep saying that wheat exports are
in peril there might be a shortage or
there is expected to be a shortage have
we already seen a dramatic drop-off in
the supply of wheat or is this still
something that people are anticipating
and they're trying to price in i think a
bit of it is anticipate is anticipated
uh we do know that ships going in and
out of the region just aren't doing it
anymore right so that that's the first
thing is traders are saying listen ships
are actually not docking uh in russia
there's a lot of ships that just aren't
docking in ukraine i mean
we know um that a number of shipping
companies have just rerouted right and
you know they've sent their ships around
to europe and then some of the ones that
were destined to go for russia or
ukraine are then being inspected in
europe by eu officials
so i think the market is anticipating
that this is actually going on um you
know we should be having more numbers
coming out over the next weeks and
months as to how big of an impact that
is right and there's still a question
how much planting are we actually going
to see in ukraine will there be a
planting season for wheat when will we
know that
well this spring obviously coming up
we'll we'll start seeing numbers or lack
of numbers i mean were
there have been some estimates as to how
much people are expecting to be planted
but again it's just really hard to you
know to to hitch your your tractor up to
those to those numbers right now just
because uh it's a war zone right and
it's just so fluid and it's impossible
to know if a farmer who's intending to
do a little bit of wheat uh
farming is actually going to have that
land you know two weeks from now and
it's also not a priority given that it
is a war zone and people we're just
trying to make sure that um the the
damages is as contained as can be when
it comes to um people and their safety
the other thing here when we talk about
plantings is the department of
agriculture is going to be releasing
some numbers fairly soon on what spring
wheat plantings will look like in the
u.s what are people thinking about in
terms of how different this will look
than what we've seen in years past you
know if we just go off the private data
that's out there right now we do think
that they're going to show
an increased amount of wheat
how much of an increase i think is
really why people are waiting to see
what the government comes out and says
at the end of march
okay got it so we'll continue to look
ahead to things like that joe doe thank
you so much bloomberg commodities
reporter joe doe on how these air
seeders are becoming really expensive
used air seeders listed at six hundred
thousand dollars this is bloomberg quick
take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elise shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
meet bloomberg's own david nicholson
now his happy place is out in the field
on the open road
but like the rest of the world lately
he's been working from home a lot more
than he's used to kovit 19 has prompted
a massive urban exodus as professionals
of every ilk yearn for more space to
live and work
as a result rural areas have exploded
and they're poised to experience a
resurgence as more and more families
pack up and leave the big city to try
out life in the burbs
but there's one problem with that
not all internet speeds are created
equal
anyone who might need to upload or
download large files for a living may
not want to pack up and move to that
cabin in the woods just yet
now david's house isn't a cabin but it
is in the woods and inexplicably his
internet is workable my internet is okay
i pay a lot for it it's around 140 a
month the download speed's great
and the upload speed is terrible which
is really bad for my work because i have
to upload these massive files but i'm
definitely one of the more lucky ones in
this community just a few miles down the
road my buddy has awful internet it's
usually under two down
and under 0.2 up so it's it's often
unusable some days it's around one
and other times it'll drop down to about
0.2.3 i just want to be able to
have internet at my house without having
to go outside the
normal
ways of acquiring internet it's it's
really frustrating we're
literally
miles a few miles away from downtown
and it just cuts off this is a problem
and the solutions are not there yet
because getting high speed internet in
rural areas on mass is something our
providers may simply not be ready for
if your internet service doesn't have
fast download and upload speeds then you
don't have high speed harmony you have
americans on average pay about 70 a
month for internet at home but in rural
areas it could cost a lot more
for a lot less service so the pricing
for a fixed wireless provider here can
be something between 80 and 150 dollars
for about 25 megabits per second however
gigabit service which is a thousand
megabits per second and symmetrical is
running at about 119 a month or 130 a
month
that's john paul he co-owns spiral fiber
an internet service provider here in
nevada county california and for the
past 10 years he's been trying to bring
an affordable fiber optic network to
town it all started when he applied to
be part of the pilot program for
google's fiber service across the
country civic boosters have been going
to extremes chanting
and marching
trying to get the search engine giant to
look at their town the internet these
days is crucial to be in the world to be
a part of the world and to be connected
to your community google ultimately went
with kansas city missouri which left
paul on a mission to get funding to lay
out fiber optic networks for gigabit
service
over the next several years he would
attend conferences and pitch venture
capitalists and apply for grants to make
his vision come to life
one of the biggest roadblocks to
building infrastructure for the internet
here in the united states are the
existing large providers
they have their land staked out they
would prefer that nobody come in and
compete against them in 2013 we applied
for a grant we went down and met with
the commissioners at the california
public utilities commission it was an
arduous process to get funded
but we finally did against all odds we
got a 16 million dollar grant and then
we went out to seek venture capital
then in march of 2020 the pandemic hit
the world
everybody got locked down and everybody
came home and everybody started using
the internet and i remember seeing on
one of the local fixed wireless
providers websites they've said hey we
know you're all staying home but please
don't use too much video and please
don't use too much bandwidth and i
thought that doesn't work
the u.s connectivity gap is far greater
compared to countries that are
considered its peers economically some
developing nations actually have better
internet than rural america like in
kenya which has a state-of-the-art fiber
optic network fed in from their
coastline the american connectivity gap
does largely affect rural areas that are
either outside of service coverage or
simply prohibitively expensive
this is rebecca she and her family moved
to nevada county just a couple miles
down the road from david
they took for granted that high-speed
internet would just exist in the area
and it's not something they even
bothered to check on before buying their
house
turns out all they got was dial-up we
wanted to move where we had a little
more space room for the kids to run
around you know just be out in the
mountains a little bit more having come
from a bigger city area where wi-fi is
pretty readily available we hadn't
really considered that
in our purchasing of the house whether
that would be an option or not when
school started and now that we are
remote learning with our children and
we're doing everything from home
we didn't have the option to do that at
our house so every day when
school would start we'd have to pack the
kids up and we'd go to
my in-law home they have a little cabin
up in this area that does have wi-fi
already rebecca's situation is the norm
in rural america according to data from
the federal communications commission
just four percent of urban americans
lack access to broadband internet that's
compared to almost 40 percent of people
who live in rural areas while that was
the case there were also racial and
socio-economic divides in terms of who
had that access in addition to that
geographic difference low-income
african-american students latino
students and first-generation
college students were more likely than
others to have only one device at home
that shared among multiple siblings and
or lack access to that actual connection
for most american towns there's also a
lack of competition forcing internet
prices up and large providers like at t
and comcast aren't incentivized to
expand service to these rural
communities this is how xfinity makes
life simple easy
so in our area we have a small imprint
of comcast but they're not going to go
out to the more rural areas it's just
not cost effective for them to do it as
a large company in order to lay fiber
cable you're actually physically digging
trenches into the ground and for
internet service providers they're
primarily focused on maximizing their
profits and so the fewer customers you
have you know in any square mile and the
more fiber you have to lay that's just
kind of harder to pencil out from a
purely economic standpoint at t released
a statement on the matter expressing the
need and desire for government
assistance to fund fiber optic expansion
to areas deemed unprofitable
comcast released a similar statement
encouraging more public-private
collaboration on this effort
federal agencies do offer grants to help
communities build broadband networks but
many have argued that there's not enough
flexibility on how to use these funds
the covet 19 relief package passed by
congress in march and signed by
president donald trump awarded 43.3
million dollars to 51 projects on the
east coast alone but it also stipulated
that these projects needed to be up and
running by december 30th
for contractors who plan projects months
and years in advance it's a scramble to
rearrange their schedules to meet that
deadline
so what we've been asking the federal
government to to consider is at least as
long as the projects are getting started
knowing the projects are being put into
place to expand both remote learning uh
working from home and opportunities like
that that are truly driven from covid
we're moving as fast as we can
regardless but hopefully they'll give us
some more time
talking to john paul it's clear that he
believes broadband is something that can
transform a community and should be
considered a public good
one of the first communities to come on
in the united states with full-on
gigabit service was chattanooga
tennessee now they're a bigger city but
they're a city that was economically in
a downturn
in the last 15 years the city of
chattanooga has turned around in an
amazing way
it's a nexus for young people to move to
it's a place where technology happens
it's not just about logging on to zoom
you know to connect with your colleagues
who might be in new york city
it's also your ability as a small
business you know operating in the town
of
nevada city or wherever it may be to
you know quickly upload your
payroll documents or something onto the
cloud or to
quickly you know swipe a customer's
credit card
there's just some really basic business
functions and mechanics that i think
people in big cities really take for
granted and that are just going to be a
much bigger challenge for small business
owners in rural areas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at this software company pay
negotiations are conducted
a little differently here it's your
colleague that said it's your colleague
that sets your salary because we trust
and we show that transparency that will
be paid back
by more trust from the people in the
team in the company
and that will create a positive feedback
loop that will benefit everyone buenos
aires based 10 pines has an open book
management style that allows employees
to have a say in all major decisions
including who they hire and how much
they're paid
in the final interview of the hiring
process the candidate meets the entire
company around 90 people who in turn
decide if they're a good fit and then
their starting salary
it's important that if this person a new
hire enters the company then everyone
will know that the salary and will be
will accept and will acknowledge that
it's it looks at least with a small
information that we have from that
person it looks fair at that time
three times a year the company has a
rates meeting in which employees can
pitch and present why they deserve a
raise before their teammates take a vote
we live in a market that it's competing
all the time for the talent and of
course one of the ways that it competes
by paying and raising salaries all the
time so it's an important aspect that
people need to know if they are being
paid a first salary or not
ten pines calls this sociocracy and
although it may sound unique its
practices are grounded in a larger trend
known as radical transparency right now
we're in really fertile ground
for this kind of idea to sprout up and i
think we're going to see many many many
things uh kind of popping up all over
the world many many experiments over the
next couple of years in this approach
and so as companies and employees start
to look towards a post-pandemic
workplace could honesty really be the
best policy
radical transparency is a concept that
broadly applied just means being
super transparent about details that a
company or an organization might
otherwise choose to keep secret or keep
hidden or limited to a certain number of
executives or leaders at a company
netflix is one of the companies best
known for its culture of radical
transparency that it says promotes
accountability
netflix the company takes radical
transparency very far and they go so far
as to have you know public discussions
or public emails
sent out to you know sometimes hundreds
of employees discussing why someone was
fired sometimes the discussions about
why someone is getting fired happen
right in front of them so that they have
a chance to share all the ways
that they made mistakes that led to them
no longer working at the company
but they also have policies that people
might see as pretty welcome so for
example they allow
their employees to sort of at their
discretion make use of their expense
accounts so that means no one's really
tracking their vacation days or their
expense spending or or things that are
you know useful to this person getting
their job done and the idea is that it's
freedom and and sort of freedom and
responsibility that is given to these
employees so that they have a chance um
to do their job the best they can
without being micromanaged
but you only have to look at netflix on
glassdoor to see that this approach
isn't for everyone
anytime you have a company culture
that's sort of extreme you have the
chance to attract people for whom it's
really a good fit and you're also going
to turn off a lot of people who
just feel that this isn't for them and
it may explain why this isn't a more
widely adopted thing because it's
difficult and it requires someone at the
top really committed to working through
the uncomfortable parts of it in order
to make it the company culture
for netflix that person at the top is
reed hastings he believes the company's
success stems from its high performance
culture in the traditional industrial
paradigm you know you have to do
something wrong to get let go you can
think of a job as sort of a property
right you know until you lose it by
abusing your position
but if you think about professional
sports you know if that team is going to
win a championship it has to have a mix
of the right players that work well
together that are the absolute best in
the world
and so we try to model ourselves like a
professional sports team so highly paid
but you got to earn your position every
year
and it's about performance and you know
that's not right for everybody some
people care mostly about job security
other people care mostly about excellent
colleagues and you know playing great
team ball to achieving something
important for the consumers
and the netflix numbers seem to show
that radical transparency is working
while it fires people at a higher rate
than the average u.s company people
actually choose to leave at a much lower
rate
but you also don't hear about the
companies for which this didn't work so
well right or the companies that might
have gotten to mid-size
and then things sort of fizzled out or
you know we look at netflix and
bridgewater and we we see these success
stories but we're also not hearing
necessarily the stories where
it was hard to keep a company culture
going as it grew much bigger or it was
hard to keep it going as the company
expanded very quickly
but beyond company success how does this
high accountability system impact the
average employee
so from a neuroscience perspective
if we think about what the brain is in
innately
craving like the brain's own goals one
of them is a sense of certainty like the
ability to predict
what's going to happen the next second
when you feel you know uncertain it
activates quite a strong threat response
in the brain which takes your attention
away from what you're trying to focus on
when certainty goes up you activate a
reward network in the brain and your
your field of view literally opens up
your perspective and how much you can
think about opens up and your ability to
be creative so one of the things with
radical transparency is people have a
lot more certainty about what's expected
of them about what great performance
looks like in any domain about what
other people are doing
how that compares to what they're doing
so it really increases your access to
information so you can feel a lot more
certain about everything that's going on
in your world and this this drive for
certainty is such a fundamental part of
the brain it's literally one of the
brain's intrinsic goals and it's not
just an increased sense of certainty
that could help us do our jobs when you
give people access to information about
who's paid what and how and what they're
doing and how the whole business works
and the whole infrastructure
people feel a much greater sense of
control they feel like they can make
decisions they feel like they are able
to to take actions and as a result
improve their career or their
performance
while a radical transparency model may
check out on a biological level
it definitely isn't a
one-size-fits-all solution
as humans we have incredible neural
diversity right there are people who
thrive
under incredible pressure and in fact
they're really bored unless there's
enormous change and uncertainty going on
and and there are people who will fall
apart if the subway schedule changes i i
will say that radical transparency as a
concept
will suit a number of kinds of
organizations or maybe even functions it
doesn't mean necessarily it will suit
every person or even necessarily every
organization it's interesting because i
think there are certain companies that
have been pushing really hard for
radical transparency for a long time for
for a decade plus um
and it hasn't had quite this moment of
you know
a moment in time in which it became very
popular i think that's because it's
probably quite hard to adjust to and and
so you see companies who really define
themselves as a company culture try to
differentiate themselves from other
companies by emphasizing radical
transparency but those companies in in
my view remain pretty few and far
between
in addition to the potential legal
issues surrounding employee performance
and termination transparency a major
hurdle for many companies is making
salaries public
yep it's 20 21 and women are still being
paid less than men for doing the same
jobs
one
step in the direction of of amending
this this
reality is to have pay transparency
in the case of paid transparency there's
this pretty strong argument that
actually hiding pay between your
employees can hold people back it lets
certain employees get paid more and
certain employees go underpaid for a
long time without knowing and so there's
i think a pretty strong argument to be
made that
you know pay transparency is more fair
a 2021 washington university study found
that pay secrecy directly contributes to
the continued pay inequality between men
and women doing the same role
i wouldn't be surprised if certain of
the more palatable or easy to digest
changes that come with radical
transparency say maybe like pay
transparency i think that's something
that more companies could get on board
with adopting it's less of a culture
shock than changing the way that you do
all sorts of feedback or firings or
meetings or sensitive things like that
and if that becomes more and more common
then you'll see companies
who want to distinguish themselves
thinking about well what's next like
what is something else that we can be
changing about how we run our business
that's going to make us better and
different from our competitors
a year of remote working has challenged
us to rethink many of our traditional
work models
and while radical transparency in its
most extreme form may not become the
norm some of its central practices like
flexibility employee autonomy and
openness may be on the way
what the the pandemic in the last year
has done is is kind of given a lot of
people
a lot more clarity about what matters to
them
and a lot more
willingness to speak up and also vote
with their feet
and i think what we're going to see as a
result is what might have taken kind of
five to ten years to happen i think it's
going to happen in one to two
in terms of organizational culture i
don't necessarily predict a revolution
but i predict some revolutionary
approaches are going to start taking
hold in organizations in the next in the
next couple of years we've seen that in
a really short amount of time things
change so dramatically and for some
organizations for example it was
impossible to think like
people working from their home all day
and from one day to the other were
forced to move to that situation and
just so that people keep working and
things keep moving and it's possible to
do such things
[Music]
[Music]
coming up on quick take
we're really really absolutely thrilled
that we have a mission to venus
we've partnered with rocket lab to
supply the scientists science team and
science instrument
and there's room for like a tiny
instrument less than one kilogram
that will go on the probe
and the probe is going to drop through
the atmosphere
very quickly
so the probe would last maybe an hour
and going through the cloud layers that
we care about
that will be about three minutes
so this mission is short
and the instrument that the team chose
it has a kind of complicated name it's
called an autofluorescein nephelometer
the instrument which in its final form
will fit inside of an estimated half a
kg payload will be the first attempt on
venus to specifically look for
biomarkers
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
standby
we are now entering the atmosphere of
venus attention
before the first space programs of the
20th century
it was thought that our closest
neighboring planet may harbor life
i can remember their images where their
dinosaurs and flying dinosaurs
thick clouds covering the surface of
venus caused humanity's imagination to
run wild
and for good reason
so at first glance venus and earth are
quite similar
they are about the same size and about
the same mass and in fact sometimes
venus is called our sister planet
but the first probes set by the soviet
union and nasa discovered a world
plagued with a poisonous greenhouse
atmosphere a sweltering surface
temperature and a crushing air pressure
the venusian surface
has a temperature of over 450 degrees
celsius so that essentially melts on the
surface of venus it's very hostile and
so attention turned to our more
hospitable neighbor mars
leaving venus largely neglected for
decades
but never forgotten scientists long
speculated that microbial life could
exist in the permanent cloud layer
atmosphere
it turns out that in the upper layers of
the atmosphere between 50 to 60
kilometers above the surface
we found conditions which are not that
different from the surface condition we
find on earth
then in 2020
evidence of biomarkers potential signs
of life were detected in that cloud
layer
maybe the case that microbial life
has adapted has a ball in order to
survive in the high clouds of venus
and although the claim was later
disputed
it reinvigorated an enthusiasm for venus
and scientists are proposing multiple
missions with a single objective
we can just pick one thing and go for it
and we can also
work on the taboo topic of the search
for life
the soviet union's venus missions gave
us the first landings and images of the
surface of another planet the first
audio recordings from the surface of
another planet
and the first and so far the only
planetary balloon missions
balloons have already been flown in the
venusian atmosphere the vega one and two
balloons so we know it works
in 1985 the two spacecraft called vega 1
and vega 2
arrived at venus
both equipped with landers and balloons
to explore the cloud layer atmosphere
the balloons separated from the crafts
lasting more than 46 hours while taking
measurements
the data from that upper cloud layer
differed greatly from the hellish
surface
so the winds have speeds of about 350 or
360 kilometers per hour
that's about
the speed of a bullet train and
corresponds to the fastest winds we have
ever measured on earth if we only look
at temperature and pressure the
conditions are very similar to the
surface conditions on earth however the
clouds which on earth consist of water
vapor they're actually made of sulfuric
acid so we are looking for life which
can survive in an extreme environment
[Music]
the cloud layer is estimated to be 50 to
100 times drier than the driest place on
earth the atacama desert in chile
dr armando azu bustos an astrobiologist
and autocoma native has spent much of
his career looking at whether life can
exist in extreme environments
we saw it at the first we would not find
any because it was so dry that is well
there's not any evidence of water here
but if you go like 30 centimeters down
the soil 50 centimeters down on
something like this right
we found a number of microorganisms
which which were still are wondering how
they're able to make it there
these organisms are called extremophiles
life that is adapted to survive in harsh
environments like a desert with no known
water source
that the camera is even as is as dry and
as old as desert as it is just you can
still find life
even in those areas telling you that it
seems that there's no limits for life on
earth and even even in the hearts of
this environment you find life
so if that is possible here how couldn't
that be the same case in other planets
the near sterile environment of the
autocoma is normally used as a testing
bed for finding life on mars
but the clouds here could give us clues
about life on venus too
by inspecting the habitability of those
clouds this is just something we're
doing now as we speak
we're trying to understand how that can
also be proposed as an analog model of
the habitabilities of the
high clouds of venusian atmosphere
but the venusian atmosphere isn't just
dry it's extremely acidic
the cave of the lighted house in mexico
contains toxic amounts of sulfuric acid
yet microbial life has evolved to use
other chemical processes to obtain
energy other than
photosynthesis already have a sample
that life was able to blow and adapt
to the most accessible environment on
earth and you cannot measure a ph lower
than zero you cannot get more accident
than that
so in life was able to
adapt to that environment why could not
be the case if life ever grows in venus
why is it important to understand the
limits for life on earth and how do we
inspect the so-called extreme
environment on earth because that gives
you an idea
on what you may expect on how you should
look for life elsewhere
so it's not easy it's not cheap to go to
mars for example
but i can go to the commodities which is
a good analog model
well we've been learning a lot about
extremophiles on earth
we've also continued to learn more about
venus since those early missions
now in terms of knowledge of venus today
we know much more about venus such as
about the existing of
prebiotic components such as ammonia
and hydrogen cyanide
we also know that the greenhouse effect
on venus started about 1 billion years
ago
so we know a lot more things about venus
thanks to
many missions which went to venus such
as orbital emissions in the past decades
very small amounts of oxygen were
detected in the atmosphere by at least
two different separate independent
probes and it's amazing because we also
don't know how oxygen would be made on
venus at the levels found and there's
sort of enough puzzles
that something really interesting is
happening on venus
recent probes to venus like the european
space agency's venus express and the
japanese aerospace exploration agency
zakatsuki has given us a lot of valuable
science
but only mars has had missions
specifically looking for organic
compounds the ingredients for life
then in 2020 this happened
it's an extraordinary possibility living
organisms floating in the clouds of
planet venus there may be some form of
life
on venus
this gas is called phosphite that what
exactly is it do we have any idea
a team led by astronomers in the uk
reported seeing the spectral signature
of phosphine in telescope data
phosphine is very unusual because on
earth it's only associated with life
either bacteria in oxygen free
environments like wetlands
or made by humans as pesticides and
other chemicals
suddenly there was a potential biomarker
for life in the venusian atmosphere and
this really changed a little bit the
picture of astrobiology research in our
solar system
while some groups have disputed the
claim saying that the phosphine signal
isn't there or at least at levels less
than previously thought it's
reinvigorated the interest in venus from
the public and scientific community so
despite all this controversy of
phosphine
people have started to re-look at the
old so-called legacy data from the
american and russian probes that went
into the venus atmosphere in the late
70s and early 80s
and
what's very intriguing is it looks like
there's evidence for phosphine from that
old data
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quicktake
one thing everyone can agree on is the
need for more research into venus
nasa and the european space agency
recently greenlit three separate
missions
veritas will map the planet's surface
in davinci plus the second nasa mission
will have an orbiter to image venus in
the ultraviolet and infrared light and
will send a probe through venus's
atmosphere
while the european space agency's
envision will take high-resolution radar
images of the planet's surface
although these missions will give us a
lot of valuable data
none of them are dedicated solely to
finding biomarkers
in order to really determine whether
there is life we would need to go there
and for us the question was immediately
how can we quickly develop and launch a
mission in order to determine whether
there's really life in the venusian
atmosphere or not and within
two weeks after the announcement of the
potential discovery of oswein we
published a report on this mission study